nations unies on a constaté que
plusieurs dizaines de milliards issus du
trafic de stupéfiants ont été absorbés
par un certain nombre de banques aux
états unis qui d'ailleurs ont été
poursuivis en justice et ont payé des
amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque fois
du lundi au jeudi l'essentiel de
l'information avec nos invités une
reporter sur le terrain tout de suite
les grands titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi à 26 avril à rambouillet en toy
citoyens et forces de l'ordre étaient
rassemblées cet après midi devant le
commissariat pour rendre hommage à
stéphanie mon fermer cette policière est
décédée à la suite d'une attaque au
couteau vendredi dernier l'assaillant
abattu par un policier était un tunisien
radicaliser selon les premiers éléments
de l'enquète trois de ses proches sont
toujours en garde à vue ce retour à
l'école pour les élèves de maternelle et
de primaire
ce lundi un protocole sanitaires
strictes et mise en place quatre cent
mille tests salivaires sont mises à
disposition
emmanuel macron et jean michel blanquer
arrêté ce matin dont vingt
établissements de melun en
seine-et-marne pour marquer cette
rentrée qui fait débat ce sera
d'ailleurs l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
l'italie joue son destin et sa
crédibilité une affirmation du chef du
gouvernement mario draghi à propos du
plan de relance économique présenté
aujourd'hui au parlement un plan sur
cinq ans de plus de 222 milliards
d'euros financés en majeure partie par
l'union européenne l'italie qui a
retrouvé un air de liberté ce lundi avec
la réouverture partielle de ses parts
restaurants et salles de spectacles dans
les trois quarts du pays
et puis nous ferons point sur les
relations tendues entre le maroc et
l'espagne qui a accepté d'accueillir le
chef des indépendantistes sahraouis du
front polisario contaminée par le copil
19 brahim ghali est entré mercredi
dernier sous un nom d'emprunt il a été
hospitalisé
incompréhension et exaspération les mots
du chef de la diplomatie marocaine à
l'ambassadeur espagnol samedi dernier
les deux royaumes s'opposent depuis 45
ans sur l'autonomie du sahara occidental
[Musique]
une cérémonie d'hommage à rambouillet
trois jours après l'assassinât d'une
policière stéphanie mon fermé tués
vendredi par un tunisien de 36 ans
radicaliser citoyens et forces de
l'ordre se sont rassemblés devant
l'hôtel de ville
nous retrouvons sur place notre reporter
thomas bonnin thomas bonsoir alors on
imagine beaucoup d'émotion lors de cette
cérémonie d'hommage à stéphanie
m'enfermer oui beaucoup d'émotion et
beaucoup de monde aussi qui se sont
rassemblés devant cet hôtel de ville de
la ville de rambouillet il ya eu donc
une cérémonie qui aura duré une dizaine
de minutes environ elle se voulait sobre
cette cérémonie et ce fut le cas
d'ailleurs il ya eu un peu déçu parce
que certains espéraient que cette
cérémonie puisse durer un peu plus
longtemps et puis il ya aussi eu des
soucis techniques alors certains c'est
un petit peu déçu à la fin de cette
cérémonie mais l'essentiel était
ailleurs l'essentiel était donc de
rendre hommage à stéphane ils ont fermé
cette policière à 2 49 ans qui a été tué
vendredi alors parmi les personnes qui
étaient présentes à cette cérémonie il y
avait bien évidemment la maire de la
ville de rambouillet mais aussi le
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
d'ailleurs l'ancien maire de la ville de
rambouillet il y avait également valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région ile
de france et puis deux membres du
gouvernement gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur et marlène schiappa ministre
chargé de la citoyenneté
ils ont déposé des gerbes de fleurs qui
sont d'ailleurs encore visibles ici au
pied de cet hôtel de ville avec
également des mots qui ont été déposés
par les habitants de rambouillet
notamment parce qu'il y avait donc
beaucoup de monde plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui se sont rassemblées une
très vive émotion beaucoup nous confier
passé des moments difficiles depuis le
vendre depuis vendredi dernier et donc
l'annoncé du décès de cette policière du
commissariat de rambouillet y avait
beaucoup de membres des forces de
l'ordre également qu'ils avaient tenu à
se rassembler ici je propose d'écouter
quelques uns des témoignages que nous
avons recueillis c'est avec 10 millions
je trouve ça je trouve ça très très
regrettable je veux dire
voilà pour le reste bon on sait dans
quelle période nous vivons c'est qu'elle
est là quels sont les tensions qui
existent
voilà la ville de rambouillet répond
répond autant qu'elle peut montre une
détermination par rapport contre le
contre le terrorisme donc voilà je
trouve ça très bien
c'était plutôt une dame très discrète
qui parlait très peu de son travail qui
pourtant était crucial pour la vie du
commissariat puisque j'avais eu
l'occasion de questionner
l'administration sur leur rôle dans le
cours de mon stage pour mon rapport de
stage et effectivement je me suis rendu
compte à quel point le rôle a été
crucial dans le dans le commissariat
pour le bon fonctionnement du
commissariat parce qu'il ya toute la
phase d' enquête mais après bon faut
quand même sortir les enquêtes et c'est
elle qui permettent le relais entre les
les institutions judiciaires et le
commissaire ya donc c'est vraiment un
rôle qui est très important depuis vers
l'année je remarque que mon
environnement se dégradent moi j'habite
refuse depuis plus de dix ans à
rambouillet je remarque ça se dégrade
alors qu'au départ c'était une ville
incroyable à vivre de plus en plus on
voit des changements de populations qui
sont installés moi ya pas plus de tarde
que deux trois mois je me suis adressé à
la guerre par un coup de barre en haut
de gamme venant de trappes
donc on a vraiment des populations qui
ont changé et donc après la sidération
étonnement je me suis dit ça mais ça ne
m'étonnerait pas tellement en fait
d'abord c'est une femme
une policière de gestion de travail
je suis triste triste de voir que la
france aime ce qu'elle est devenue la
france je suis écoeuré de voir ce qui se
passe et jusqu'au gouvernement nous fait
voilà vous l'avez entendu tristesse
sidération et un peu de colère aussi
dans les discours des personnes qui se
sont rassemblées ici ils ont donc pu
suivre cette cérémonie d'hommage il faut
noter que la famille de la victime la
famille de stéphanie m'enfermer était
également présente avec beaucoup
d'émotions vous pouvez l'imaginer
notez aussi que cette cérémonie s'est
achevée par une marseillaise qui a été
chanté à l'unisson ici par les habitants
les habitants maintenant attendait des
actes de la part des pouvoirs publics
ils demandent à ce que à des dispositifs
législatifs puisse être peut être adapté
pour éviter que ce genre d'événement ne
se reproduise
alors mercredi gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur va déposer en
conseil des ministres une proposition de
loi antiterroriste merci beaucoup à vous
de m'abonner pour toutes ces précisions
la rentrée scolaire après trois semaines
sans école pour les enfants de
maternelle et de primaire
pour l'occasion le protocole sanitaire
est stricte quatre cent mille tests
salivaires sont déployés la règle elle
ne change pas un cas de kobe dans une
classe implique sa fermeture en fait le
point avec cyrielle brice une rentrée
des classes un peu particulière après
trois semaines de fermeture des
établissements
les maternelles et primaires retrouvent
le chemin de l'école un retour entre
joie et appréhensions se trouve non
on va avoir une semaine d'école et puis
après ça va être
ça va être pliée parce que voilà il y
aura des cas il suffit d'un cas pour que
sa ferme donc on a un petit peu peur de
ça je suis content parce et gâter les
ont pas et puis en plus 10 boulot
vraiment c'est pas facile donc moi je me
réjouis qu'est l'école ait pu le plan ce
matin les plus inquiets sur le collège
et d'autres en fonction collège jeu
c'est un peu plus compliqué pour on a un
peu peur du brésil mais bon une rentrée
sous haute tension avec la mise en place
d'un protocole sanitaires strictes
jean-michel bancaire l'a assuré quatre
cent mille dépistages hebdomadaires vont
être réalisés si le gouvernement affirme
avoir commandé 60 4 millions d'autos
test pour le corps enseignant
bon nombre d'écoles se sont retrouvés
bredouille en ce jour de rentrée
autre mesure de précaution prônée par le
ministre de l'éducation faire manger les
enfants à la maison plutôt qu'à la
cantine avec le retour des beaux jours
l'école en plein air est également une
solution à privilégier selon l'exécutif
le gouvernement a été clair le moindre
cas de kovy 19 entraînera la fermeture
automatique de la classe concernée
l'école n'est pas responsable de
l'épidémie
c'est un protocole très sévère qui va
forcément amener à un nombre non
négligeable de fermetures de classes
je préfère une petite minorité de
classes fermées que l'ensemble des
classes si les maternelles et primaires
sont de retour en présentiel
ce n'est pas le cas des collégiens et
lycéens rentrés virtuel pour ces
derniers ce lundi avant de retrouver les
bancs de l'école le 3 mai prochain
si jean michel blanquer promettait une
amélioration de l'outil ma classe à la
maison proposé par le cned le démarrage
semble bien difficile impossible de se
connecter ce matin pour bon nombre
d'enseignants et d'élèves
une rentrée non sans embûche pour les
petits comme pour les grands
et selon l'unesco entre mars 2020 et
mars 2021 la france a été le pays
européen qui a le moins fermé les écoles
avec 10 semaines de fermeture au total à
6 millions d'élèves ont repris
chemin des écoles aujourd'hui dans un
contexte sanitaire toujours difficile
alors est-ce que c'est trop tôt c'est
justement l'objet d'un autre face à face
[Musique]
bonsoir à vous rodrigo arenas
vice-président lcpe y avoue également
nicolas guiet vous êtes enseignant
membre des stylos rouges nicolas glières
vous dites que c'est trop tôt cette
réouverture
mais l'objectif on sait pour le
gouvernement emmanuel macron c'est
d'éviter un trou d'air éducatif alors le
'trou d'air' éducatif a fait zéro mort
pour le moment on est à 110 milles mort
du co lead condat à 400 morts
aujourd'hui vous savez que lundi les
chiffres sont en général très bas
400 morts + t-il personne n'aurait à 1%
d'hospitalisation plus jour après jour
entre la vie des gens la vie c'est à
dire la vie et la mort et garder ses
enfants trois jours à la maison ce qui
est la réalité pas trois semaines de
fermeture à vous ai dit trois semaines
tout à l'heure il ya eu trois jours de
fermeture en primaire quatre jours en
collège bon désolé mais ça me paraît pas
être le bout du monde pour sauver la vie
des gens et pour empêcher la
contamination
partout où l'on peut ce n'est pas une
situation idéale mais je rappelle que
les stylos rouges demandent depuis le
mois de juin les demis groupe partout
c'était une solution pragmatique avec la
prise en charge par les collectivités
locales
monsieur blanc caire a tout refusé en
bloc n'a jamais rien voulu entendre
ils voulaient du sang pour sang de
présentiel c'est notre bol saône à
roanne où il ne veut pas entendre parler
de l'épidémie pour lui elle n'existe pas
et on en est là aujourd'hui
donc le protocole qui hélas n'est en
place avec un cas une fermeture il est
stricte enfin je j'ose dire enfance il
n'a jamais été strict quasiment depuis
septembre mais c'est mal fait c'est à
dire quand en primaire et en maternelle
on a 25 30 35 élèves par classe de
nouveau le gyrus va de nouveau circuler
à cause des écoles des parents des
familles la société va être contaminé
les personnels d'éducation dont tout le
monde se moque parents d'élèves compris
vont être de nouveau contaminés et on va
avoir de nouveau des morts des colis de
long des gens qui vont être très mal je
trouve ça déplorable on a un
gouvernement qui ne fait rien comme
d'habitude on a mis une semaine à fermer
les frontières par rapport à l'inde
rapport au brésil
mais qu'est ce que fait ce gouvernement
qu'est ce que font ces gens
est ce que c'est ça le en même temps où
il pleut en même temps c'est ne rien
faire ne pas protéger le pays ne pas
protéger les profs ne pas protéger les
flics ne pas protéger l'hôpital sabrer
dans les dépenses
décès des salaires des services publics
voilà ce qu'est ce gouvernement voilà ce
que représente aussi monsieur blanc cas
là je le répète on porte plainte contre
lui pour ces raisons là parce qu'il ne
nous protège pas parce qu'il met en
danger les populations et on le prouve
encore avec cette reprise stupide
crétine aujourd'hui parce que des gens
estiment que garder trois jours ou huit
jours des enfants la maison est un
calvaire sur leurs propres sont je le
répète j'ai utilisé trois semaines on
pourra les collèges et les lycées
puisque trois saisons tandis temps ciel
rodrigo arenas est vrai 1,4 qu'ovide une
fermeture un protocole sanitaire très
strict alors ça veut dire que pour les
parents d'élèves ils doivent se préparer
de toute façon à la fermeture d'autres
classes parce qu'il y en aura c'est
certain
les parents d'élèves se prépare aux
fermetures de classes depuis maintenant
des mois et ça fil des mois et c'est la
leçon du premier confinement d'ailleurs
qui indiquait que consigne c'était un
métier et qu'on ne peut pas demander aux
parents de jouer au maître à la détresse
parce que simplement ils ont d'autres
compétences d'assez notre trop
d'altitude mais qu'aujourd'hui nous
lourd et amour depuis maintenant l'été
comme l'a fait l'italie qui est une
embauche massive d'enseignants qui soit
faite
parce que s'il n'y a pas d'embauché
massif d'enseignants alors on ne peut
pas mettre en place la distanciation
physique
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence les
parents quand ils mettent leurs enfants
à l'école les maîtres la boule au ventre
pourquoi parce que les enfants peut
provenir chargé de coville est contaminé
la famille mais aussi parce que il est
inacceptable que nos enfants contaminent
leurs enseignants aucun parent ne crie
sur les enseignants au diable au
contraire nous leur confions ce qui nous
est de plus cher et c'est parce que nous
confions aux quais de plus cher que nous
essayons de les défendre de les protéger
évidemment dans la limite de notre
exercice puisque nous sommes que des
parents d'élèves au départ de cette
rentrée vous dites que ça te rend très
là les prématurés comme les koalas
glières ou pas alors nous sommes des
parents d'élèves c'est à dire que nous
ne sommes pas habilités il me semble il
faut que chacun assume entre guillemets
ses compétences et il ne semble pas que
les parents d'élèves et la compétence de
10 risque il faut ouvrir
fermer les écoles en revanche ce que
nous disons et je pense que nous sommes
assez lent d'accord voir en accord avec
votre représentant des stylos rouges sur
le plateau mais aussi avec les
organisations syndicales qui elles ni
langue avec le avec le ministère de
façon on va dire plus conventionnelles
même s'il ne les écoute pas et les
entend pas non plus mais je vous met à
l'aise aussi un les fédérations de
parents non plus c'est ce que
aujourd'hui tout porte à croire et tous
ceux tout montre que les moyens ne sont
pas au rendez vous pour permettre cette
sérénité et nous nous soutenons nous
mais place on du côté de l'académie de
médecine qui dit clairement que les
mesures par exemple les autotests tels
qu'ils sont mis sur la table ne sont pas
efficaces est d'ailleurs le seul pays
qui le fait sur lequel il ya un bilan
s'appelait de l'allemagne l'allemagne
recul sur ce point là car ils n'ont pas
été efficaces pour pouvoir déceler
notamment les symptomatique et donc
protéger les enseignants les élèves mais
aussi des familles
donc voilà aujourd'hui la situation qui
se pose c'est que nous avons des mesures
qui sont mises en place la vitesse d'un
diesel face à un comique qui lui avance
au super nous nous réclamions il ya 13
mois
il ya 13 mois nous demandons que des
enfants soient testés pourquoi de betty
à le tester parce qu'il revenait d'un
voyage scolaire
la réponse était à l'époque de deux
membres éminents de la majorité
présidentielle que nous étions des
personnes qui entretenait une psychose
qui était irresponsable fois saper une
grippette
on va on en voit sur le ballon on va
avancer sur un protocole mais on va
danser c'est justement sur le détail du
protocole sanitaire strict avec les
tests mais je voudrais qu'on regarde
cette ses propos de jean michel blanc
coeur justement à propos du risque de
fermeture d'éclat dans cette carrière va
compliquer la fermeture des classes dès
le premier cas de kovy d' il y aura donc
nécessairement un nombre non négligeable
de fermeture mais je préfère avoir à
fermer 1 % des classes que 100% des
écoles la pochette bancaire donc elles
affirment ils préfèrent une petite
minorité de classes fermées plutôt que
de fermer l'ensemble des écoles
il a raison le ministre de l'éducation
de raisonner ainsi
nicolas glières alors déjà je ne sais
pas comment il peut savoir que ce sera
un pour cent des classes c'est absurde
on a encore un ministre qui décide
en fait il ne sait rien du tout il est
spécialiste de rien du tout il n'est
même pas bon dans son propre mythe il
des banques en comme concrètement et
encore mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
chiffre de 1% comment s'est il plu ce
sera important de classes dans
lesquelles il y aura un cadre cosy qui
nécessitera la fermeture
encore une fois rien n'a été prévu rien
n'a été envisagée les parents d'élèves
et les personnels d'éducation de terrain
sont mis devant le fait accompli sans
arrêt rien n'est envisagé
rien n'est anticipée rien n'est préparé
vous avez vous l'avez expliqué vous même
tout à l'heure dans le sujet qu'on a vu
les serveurs des blocs encore
aujourd'hui mais ça n'a pas été préparée
la 13 millions d'élèves en france quand
le disque en ciel a été mis en place
rien n'était prêt on a accusé monsieur
poutine la russie
on a accusé la corée du nord donc là
c'est quoi c'est encore ce sont encore
des hackers russes qui se sont acharnés
sur le bal le collège de montigné
lerebours enfin c'est ni fait ni à faire
on a en mépris en plus en face de nous
on au ministère
puisque monsieur blanc quatre ans les
gens pour des idiots donc non il ne
fallait pas rouvrir telle que ces faits
j'entends et je pense qu'on est tout à
fait d'accord avec monsieur arenas là
dessus ce qui ne va pas ce n'est pas de
réouvrir nous ne voulions pas on ferme
on ne voulait pas fermée si on avait
écouté ce que nous proposions que des
mois de juin les choses se seraient bien
passés et puis il ya ces histoires d'où
tout est histoire des vaccins les
histoires des masses en avant par les
opinions son jeu on va juste faire
réagir aux dragons à rennes elle sera
sûre à propos des deux ce qu'a affirmé
justement jean michel branquart sur la
fermeture des classes potentiel c'est
donc dans la méthode c'est assez
choquant c'est choquant parce que jean
michel blanquer remet les enseignants le
savent aussi et les parents d'élèves de
surcroît et les élèves encore plus
puisque c'est eux qui en sont victimes
en dernier ressort aujourd'hui le
problème numéro un de l'éducation
nationale mais depuis des années c'est
le recrutement
donc tant qu'il n'y aura pas un système
scolaire qui permettent de recruter des
enseignants en nombre suffisant alors ce
n'est pas 1 % 2 % à 3 %
parce qu'il n'en sait rien il n'en sais
rien pour une simple et bonne raison
c'est que les absences non remplacées
qui sont comptabilisés par le ministère
de l'éducation nationale sont celles qui
sont supérieurs à quinze jours c'est à
dire celles qui sont comptabilisés avec
des recours pour les parents qui
pourraient attaquer et ils le font
d'ailleurs toujours avec succès au
tribunal administratif
pour 10 continuité pédagogique parce que
les enfants m'ont dit droit dans ce pays
et que ça te plaise ou pas jean michel
blanc terre que ça plaise ou pas à qui
que ce soit dans ce pays les enfants ont
des droits et qu'en l'occurrence
l'éducation nationale a le devoir de
donner un certain nombre d'heures de
cours avec les enseignants en présence
fassent à leur enfant alors évidemment
le coc vide et s'est invitée ce qui est
ce qui est désolant dans cette
philosophie là dans cette approche du
ministère actuelle c'est qu'on prépare à
l'échec
on prépare à l'échec c'est à dire a
anticipé le fait qu'il n'y aura pas des
enseignants partout à chaque fois que ce
sera nécessaire
on prépare les chèques à savoir à ses
élèves de bts qu'on entasse comme comme
des bétaillères dans des dents des n'y a
qu'au vide a passé des examens sous
peine de recevoir 1 0 et qui in fine et
on prépare en disant c'est pas grave si
vous échouez vous passerez le rattrapage
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui dire aux
enseignants dire aux élèves 10 euros par
an ne vous inquiétez pas on prépare les
chais il nous semble nous que la
philosophie grecque positive elle doit
préparer à la réussite mais préparés à
la réussite ça vous dire autre chose ça
veut dire mettre les moyens financiers
mettent les moyens humains mais des
moyens matériels pour réussir et c'est
autre chose alors jusqu'à ce que les
moyens car sonas miles euros plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros à son
collègue du budget alors les moyens
financiers ça concerne évidemment le
protocole sanitaires strictes inquiète
mise en place qui comprend notamment des
dépistages massif le nom brassage entre
les places d'abord ce protocole est ce
qu'il est suffisant et surtout est-ce
qu'il est applicable
nicolas glières mais le protocole depuis
le début au niveau de la distanciation
sociable n'est pas applicable
monsieur arenas l'a très bien dit quand
on est à 30 35 par classe il n'ya pas
distanciation sociale on répète depuis
des mois qu on est à 40 centimètres les
uns des autres et c'est une réalité
donc rien que ce critère essentiel de
distanciation social n'est pas possible
l'italie effectivement à embaucher 70
mille enseignants pour créer la
distanciation social pour baisser le
nombre d'élèves par classe ils le voient
là pour qu'il y ait cette distanciation
la france n'a rien fait mais selon ker
un rendu de l'argent avec un air béat
heureux à monsieur le maire pour montrer
qu'il était un bon élève le doigt sur la
couture pas de purificateurs d'air on a
rien dans les classes
il dit que brasser l'air et plus
mais c'est vraiment cette idée là fait
une descente les purificateurs d'air
c'est une des récentes
ça va venir non ah non on le demande
depuis des mois aussi on le demande
depuis des mois séparés sont du tout
qu'il sait n'a pas été entendu en fait
c'est simple que ce soit la fcpe les
syndicats les stylos rouges
aucune de nos demandes n'a été
satisfaite je dis bien aucune on on va
paraître le goji de riom et sur le
dépistage massif
rodrigo brana le dépistage massif est ce
que ça ça va être une réussite
il ya plusieurs phases notamment au
niveau primaire avec les tests
salivaires mais on attend 600 milles mon
test salivaire d'ici la mi mai écoutez
les tests ça libère les autotests vous
appelez ça la technologie qui vous
arrangent c'était au moins il ya treize
mois est à 13 mois qu'on ne te
fédération le demande et comme je disais
tout à l'heure quand les onze enfants
revenaient d'un voyage scolaire de
lombardie ou aldi sud est aujourd'hui la
la la présence du co vide la présence de
la pandémie et la vitesse de procap
vague de propagation avec les variants
qui s'invite ce n'est plus des autos
tête vont nous avons besoin c'est de
vacciner
est ce que vous savez qu un autotest c3
12 d'astrazeneca la même avec lequel je
me stresser vacciner c'est cela dont
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui il ya
besoin de vacciner en urgence les
enseignants y compris en dessous de 50
50 mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
limite quand on est en face à des
enfants en sachant qu'en plus des
enseignants les plus jeunes sont les
plus sensibles parce qu'ils sont cesser
ce sont ceux qui sont avec les enfants
les plus jeunes et donc les enfants les
plus jeunes de maternelle et primaire
sont ceux qui sont le plus emprunté plus
en proximité avec les enseignants donc
cette barrière d'âge n'a pas de sens n'a
pas de sens pratique
c'est aussi vacciner ce qu'on appelle
les tailles des aléas unis sache ce
qu'on a les personnes qui font la
cantine les personnes qui nettoie les
écoles sur toutes celles et ceux qui
sont en contact avec les écoles sont en
contact avec nos enfants et qui ne
peuvent pas aller travailler avec la
peur au ventre on ne peut pas enseigner
dans ces conditions le gouvernement
le gouvernement qui a recommandé
les autotests soit effectif y compris
pour le personnel dès aujourd'hui
nicolas glières ce que ça fonctionne et
est ce que vous vous avez utilisé un
autotest alors motion collège donc je
suis en distance yale encore pour le
moment il est mais de toute façon
maintenant distanti lct recommandèrent
dès aujourd'hui bah oui enfin je dis
renard qu'on a nous n'a rien reçu déjà
de façon générale rien ne sera envoyé
aux établissements la logistique est
trop importante
je rappelle qu'on est quand même 880
milles îles à 880 milles enseignants et
ça ne prend pas en compte les
surveillants les atsem les abbesses h
qui sont collés aux élèves en permanence
donc ça ne sera pas fait on n'aura pas
ces chiffres sont faux c'est de la com
encore une fois comme sur le vaccin
comme sur les masques on a toujours je
n'ai toujours pas de masque chirurgical
on ne nous a pas envoyé de masque on est
toujours laissé libre dimanche foisonner
qu'on nous avait fourni il ya des mois
on n'a jamais rien eu d'autre
alors quand même c'est ça l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui et les quantités
j'ai toujours la même chose et les
cantines rodrigo arenas avec cette
rentrée justement le gouvernement qui
demande aux parents de ne pas envoyer si
possible leurs enfants à la cantine côté
gauche une accélération trouve que c'est
extrêmement choquant comme comme comme
philosophie encore une fois c'est à dire
que en gros qu'est ce qu'on est en train
de dire on est en train de dire que les
par nature les moyens d'aller chercher
leurs gamins de prendre une nounou et de
les faire manger à la maison alors s'il
vous plaît retirer les du cluster parce
que c'est ce que fait le ministre et
reconnaît que le que la cantine scolaire
est un cluster et ceux qui ont pas le
choix
les enfants pauvres les enfants qui
n'ont pas les moyens de d'avoir
quelqu'un qui allait chercher pendant
que les parents travaillent
c'est dommage pour eux c'est tant pis
aller vous contaminer mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette logique enfin il me
semble que la république c'est autre
chose que la solidarité l'égalité la
fraternité
les valeurs de la république comme le
ministre entend souvent mettre sur la
table c'est autre chose
nous ne sommes que des solutions
existent on sait aujourd'hui faire à
manger pour un collectif d'enfants
ce qu'il manque c'est la distanciation
physique c'est de créer des conditions
de manger sereinement et pour ça vous
savez les villes les départements les
régions l'état lui-même ont des salles à
disposition pour permettre aux enfants
de manger dehors
j ailleurs de mettre des barnums dans la
classe de maître de mettre des
protections dans l'est dans l'espace
dans les gymnases pour pouvoir faire ces
distanciation physique et comme il ya
beaucoup de parents qui sont en
télétravail comme moi d'ailleurs
eh bien vous savez dans nos boîtes et
ben il ya des salles qui sont
disponibles voilà ce que ça veut dire
mettre tous les efforts en commun parce
que on se rend compte que les exigences
sont surtout du côté des écoles
publiques
mais du côté des écoles privées là ça se
passe un peu notre avance sur l'abeille
c'est un problème un mot sur la
vaccination parce que c'est aussi un
enjeu qui est posée par cette rentrée un
c'est pas facile d'avancer pour
l'instant ce sont les plus de 55 ans au
niveau des enseignants qui sont qui
peuvent se faire vacciner avec
astrazeneca on sait qu'il ya une
défiance vis-à-vis de ce vaccin
vous croyez que le membre de doses ne
permet pas de vacciner l'ensemble des
enseignants aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
faut en faire aussi une priorité pour
conclure mais bien sûr qu'il faut faire
une priorité on demande depuis longtemps
que tous les personnels d'éducation de
terrain qui le souhaitent en contact
avec les élèves soient vaccinés on a
tourné toujours pas une priorité puisque
a été estimé que les enseignants aux
plus de 55 ans serait considérée comme
les autres gens de 55 ans et plus dans
la population française
donc on est en première ligne on est en
danger on est les seuls à ne pas
connaître la distanciation sociale dans
ce pays ont subi le protocole le moins
stricte du pays dans les écoles de
manière générale nous on a pas loin
d'être vacciné arena se disait tout à
l'heure il faudrait que tous les
enseignants tous les personnels qui sont
proches des élèves atsem à message à eux
deux les surveillants 3-1 puissent être
vaccinés s'ils le souhaitent le problème
c'est qu'on a viré l'intégralité des
infirmières scolaires des médecins
scolaires qui sont quasiment inexistants
on n'a pas de médecine du travail ça
c'est une de nos grandes revendications
aux côtés de nos salaires bien entendu
et on a personne qui peut s'occuper de
faire ces vaccins je rappelle qu'en 1880
mail rien que les enseignants donc
comment eux n'y a aucune logistiques
donc comment mettre en place cela vite
c'est impossible
le gouvernement pour nous d'y construire
et donc c'est ça la vaccination à la
priorité la vaccination pour pour les
enseignants ecoutez-nous musique dont
nous étions parfaitement en phase avec
le président de la république quand il
annonçait que courant avril tous les
enseignants seraient seraient vaccinés
on a eu du mal à le croire mais on est
plutôt
à faire confiance malheureusement les
enseignants le dise
et d'ailleurs je comprends tout à fait
que les stylos rouges porte plainte
contre leur employeur parce que c'est
leur santé qui doit être assurée c'est
la première des responsables
d'employeurs que d'autre que de veiller
à la sécurité de dd salariés dans toutes
les professions
eh bien il me semble que la ta parole
n'a pas été tenue comme le ministre qui
promettait au mois de janvier qui aurait
un million de tests
aujourd'hui on en est vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure à 400 milles par semaine
on est quand même quatre mois plus tard
la question c'est que on ne peut pas
continuer à organiser la défiance de la
parole publique
aujourd'hui la parole du président de la
république celle du ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est du chef du
gouvernement engage et il nous semble
nous que plutôt que de faire des
conférences de presse qui ont tendance à
rassurer nous nous invitons vraiment les
journalistes à faire des enquêtes à
regarder comment ça se passe sur le
terrain
comment est-ce que ces chiffres se
réaliser ce que effectivement 5000 à
8000 enseignants et nous sommes
favorables seront embauchés pour pallier
aux absences sont remplacées
est ce que les millions de tests seront
refaits est ce que vous voyez c'est ça
aujourd'hui on a besoin il faut que les
paroles rejoignent des actes et non pas
que ça reste des paroles en l'air parce
qu'il n'y a rien de pire pour un parent
que de mettre son enfant à l'école en
sachant qu'à la fin le gamin va se
retrouver à la maison livré à lui-même
pour faire les cours que les enseignants
leur donne en sachant pertinemment et
c'est une très grande violence
intriguant harcèlement pour les
enseignants qui savent qu'ils ne
tiendront pas les programmes qu'ils ne
pourront pas passer des examens dans des
conditions décentes et pour autant le
ministre continue à se montrer ses seins
à cela c'est du harcèlement au travail
il faut que ça cesse le gouvernement qui
promet donc un objectif de 600 mille
tests salivaires à l'animé 64 millions
d'autos test merci beaucoup à vous
rodrigo arenas vice-président la fcpe
merci à vous également nicolas glières
cet enseignant membre des stylos rouges
un merci et dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l'italie bars restaurants
salles de spectacle ont rouvert ce lundi
est là bas alors que
un moment vient de présenter son plan de
relance de plus de 222 milliards d'euros
et puis nous parlerons des relations
entre le maroc et l'espagne alors que
madrid a accueilli ce week end le chef
du front polisario a tout de suite sur
rtl france
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement a percuté et on ne peut
pas considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde y la
pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez 20h30 heure française
le conflit entre astrazeneca l'europe se
règlera devant les tribunaux la
commission européenne a annoncé saisir
la justice contre le laboratoire suède
ou britanniques pour non respect des
contrats d'approvisionnement en vaccin
est les précisions 7 avec grégoire
brousmiche le début d'une guerre
juridique entre bruxelles et astrazeneca
après plusieurs mois de rapports tendus
entre les deux parties la patience des
27 états membres a atteint ses limites
ce lundi la commission européenne a
annoncé lancer une action en justice
contre le laboratoire suédo britannique
elle pointe du doigt un non respect des
contrats de livraisons des précieuses
dose de sérum
la commission a entamé vendredi dernier
une action en justice contre la société
astrazeneca pour violation du contrat
d'achat anticipé
la raison de cette action et que les
termes du contrat ou certains des termes
du contrat n'ont pas été respectées et
le groupe n'a pas été en mesure de
proposer une stratégie fiable pour
assurer la livraison des doses dans les
délais ce qui nous importe dans ce cas
c'est que nous voulons nous assurer
qu'ils y ait une livraison rapide d'un
nombre suffisant de doses auxquelles les
citoyens européens un droit et qui ont
été promises sur la base du contrat oft
il faut dire que seule la livraison d'un
quart des 120 millions de doses promises
au premier trimestre par le groupe
pharmaceutique a été assurée et le bilan
du deuxième trimestre devrait également
être largement insuffisant astrazeneca
s'est de son côté justifié et affirme
avoir je cite complètement respecter les
contrats jugeant ces poursuites
judiciaires infondées
les vaccins sont difficiles à fabriquer
comme l'ont montré les problèmes
rencontrés par plusieurs groupes en
europe et dans le monde
nous faisons des progrès pour relever
les défis techniques et notre production
s'améliore un litige autour duquel les
deux parties semblent d'ores et déjà
perdante centre les retards accumulés de
l'europe dans sa stratégie vaccinale et
l'image une fois de plus écornée du
groupe astrazeneca l'épidémie qui
continue de progresser dans de nombreux
pays et pourtant le cap du millier
deux doses de vaccin administrées dans
le monde a été franchi ce week end mais
les inégalités sont nombreuses
rien que pour la journée de samedi neuf
cent mille nouveaux cas ont été recensés
le point avec françois 10 kilic ses
libertés l'élite
c'est un miracle dans les rues de
jérusalem les habitants fait une liberté
retrouvée
les masques sont tombés et les terrasses
de café ont retrouvé leurs clients avec
près de six israéliens sur dix déjà
complètement vaccinés
israël est de loin le pays dont la
campagne de vaccination est la plus
avancée
un résultat qui s'explique par une
volonté politique mais aussi
technologique en échange d'un accès
rapide à des millions de doses le pays a
offert à pfizer les données médicales de
l'effet du vaccin sur sa population
israël disposant des données médicales
digitalisées de l'ensemble de ses
habitants dans le peloton de tête
figurent également les émirats arabes
unis avec 51 % de sa population vaccinée
le royaume uni ou encore les états unis
avec l'ue 40% des américains vacciner et
si la plupart des pays en développement
ont désormais commencer à injecter le
précieux sérum à leur population
la vaccination reste un privilège des
pays développés un déséquilibre flagrant
dénoncé à plusieurs reprises par le
directeur général de l'om s en moyenne
dans les pays à revenu élevé
près d'une personne sur quatre a reçu un
vaccin dans les pays à faible revenu
c'est une personne sur plus de 500 fans
de let me répéter je répète une personne
sur quatre contre une source en sang il
faut dire que le dispositif censé
garantir une distribution équitable des
vaccins dans le monde peine à accélérer
la cadence
kovacs devait atteindre le chiffre de
100 millions de doses de vaccin fin mars
mais mi avril seuls 40 millions de doses
ont été distribuées
l'ours est en effet très loin de les
objectifs affichés puisque même au
départ le programme kovacs l'idée
c'était que tous les achats soit fait de
manière groupée et qu'il soit ensuite
redistribuée de manière équitable entre
les différents pays mondiaux alors
évidemment c'est pas le cas puisqu'il ya
eu un nationalisme vaccinale qui s'est
fortement opérés notamment au niveau des
pays développés qui sont évidemment ceux
qui avaient la plus grande capacité à
acquérir ce vaccin
malgré le milliard de doses de vaccin
administrées l'épidémie continue de
progresser
samedi neuf cent mille cas ont été
enregistrés dans le monde dont un tiers
sur le territoire indien
plus d'un an après le début de la
pandémie l'italie de son côté ceux des
confirment progressivement écoles bars
restaurants et lieux culturels rouvre
partiellement leurs portes avec des
mesures sanitaires strictes est les
italiens peuvent désormais profiter des
terrasses alors que le chef du
gouvernement a lui présenté aujourd'hui
son plan de relance pour faire face à la
crise qui touche le pays les détails
d'amaya seront comme un air de retour à
la normale ce lundi l'italie a rouvert
les portes de ses écoles
[Musique]
restaurant
ou encore cinéma
un déconfinement progressif qui entre en
vigueur pour les régions classée en
jaune soit le niveau le plus bas de
risque sanitaire
les écoles accueillent 70% des effectifs
en présentiel une présence total n'étant
pas possible du fait des transports
toujours limité un retour dans les
établissements scolaires qui sonne comme
un soulagement pour les élèves en
tissage en présentiel et sûrement mieux
que de le faire depuis il est certain
qu'en retour à presque 100% nous aident
en tant qu'étudiant donc nous espérons
que nous pourrons continuer comme salle
pour les derniers mois pour nous en
particulier qui sûrement cinquième année
être en cinquième année et préparer un
examen final avec l'apprentissage en
présentiel et sûrement mieux que de le
faire depuis chez soi et du côté de la
culture les cinémas et les musées
peuvent à nouveau accueillir du public à
hauteur de 50% et avec un contrôle
systématique de la température à
l'entrée ya de rouvrir leurs portes
un protocole strict mis en place
également pour les restaurants qui sont
autorisés à servir en terrasse et le
soir jusqu'au couvre-feu de 22 heures un
scénario inédit depuis six mois qui
permet à près de 140000 bars restaurants
et pizzerias de rouvrir leurs portes
je suis très heureux de pouvoir utiliser
les petites tables à l'extérieur à
partir d'aujourd'hui malheureusement le
temps n'est pas au beau fixe mais on
espère que pendant la semaine
les choses vont s'améliorer au moins
nous avons une chose de plus à offrir
aux gens c'est un peu une renaissance
compromettre l'été dsit à partir du 1er
juillet piscine salle de sport et parcs
d'attractions devrait connaître le même
sort après des mois d'ouvertures et de
fermetures à répétition
l'italie espère pouvoir profiter de la
période estivale
mais selon les spécialistes un nouveau
pic de contagion pourrait compromettre
l'été des italiens sur un territoire qui
enregistre actuellement 300 décès par
jour en moyenne
l'italie l'un des pays les plus durement
touchés par le cos vide avec près de 120
mille décès souffre d'une violente crise
économique
c'est dans ce contexte que mario draghi
a présenté ce lundi devant le parlement
son plan de relance de 190 milliards
d'euros
un plan financé par l'union européenne
sur lequel se jouera le destin de
l'italie selon le chef du gouvernement
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis milan en italie avec camilla
genovese médecin c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors l'italie qui assouplit ses mesures
de restriction mais c'est un
assouplissement contre la vie quand même
des scientifiques votre pays qui
continuent d'enregistrer en moyenne plus
de 300 morts chaque jour mario draghi de
son côté et parle de risque calculé est
ce que c'est un pari risqué
bonsoir effectivement les on nettoie sa
des réouvertures alors c'est une
situation de très compliquée très
délicate
il faut que les italiens saches que même
si on a plus de liberté même si on peut
retourner au restaurant même si on peut
retourner au cinéma les la situation
épidémique ne change pas donc il faut
toujours être alerte il faut toujours
prendre des mesures de contention du
virus entre entre les personnes c'est
vrai que avec le beau temps les
personnes se retrouvent quand même dans
les parcs
c'est faut faire attention de toute
façon le gouvernement est ce qu'il a
cédé à la pression des dirigeants la
pression si économique
oui c'est vrai que la situation est très
compliquée très grave ici les il ya
beaucoup de restaurants de magasins en
faillite on voit ça dans les rues de
milan moi j'habite à milan mais même
dans toutes les villes d'italie c'est la
même chose donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
retrouver un temps de rencontre entre
les citoyens et les médecins et la santé
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas facile
5 2 millions d'italiens qui sont
désormais vaccinés 350 mille doses de
vaccins administrés chaque jour dans
votre pays depuis quelques jours
d'ailleurs gouvernement a rendu la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants et
et les pharmaciens est-ce que l'italie
peut compter sur cette campagne de
vaccination pour réussir son thé
confinement ben moi je l'espère là c'est
vrai qu'on a augmenté les doses de
vaccins administrés chaque jour on
procède assez efficacement
on compte de rejoindre les cinq cent
mille doses par jour c'est vrai que
c'est un des gros chiffres mais nous en
tant que médecin on s'implique dans ses
dents cela et on sait que les citoyens
aussi veulent se faire vacciner veut
sortir de cette situation donc on espère
que cela c'était assez rapidement et
comment se déroule justement la campagne
de vaccination est ce qu il ya d une
défiance vis-à-vis de certains vaccins
astrazeneca par exemple comme c'est le
cas chez nous en france
malheureusement oui il ya quelques
préjugés par rapport à ce vaccin fait
des personnes qui ne veulent plus se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca et c'est
vrai que les l'opinion publique est très
influencée en affluence et aussi parce
que longtemps on l'entend aux noix aux
infos bon en tant que médecins et
scientifiques
moi je me suis fait personnellement
vaccinés par la astrazeneca et je prends
dans la science et je sais qu'il ya les
risques ne sont pas plus forts que les
bénéfices donc j'espère que mes
concitoyens considèrent vaccine de toute
façon et l'évolution des variants qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire là-dessus
il ya une grosse inquiétude en ce moment
dans toute l'europe à cause de ce
nouveau variant le vario indien oui
c'est ça c'est vrai c'est vrai que voilà
le l'important c'est de ceux de procéder
avec les vaccinations de continuer et de
terminer enfin deux voilà deux d'avancé
et des vaccinations dans le plus le plus
rapidement possible afin de d'éviter la
propagation de ces variants parce qu'on
sait que de toute façon la plupart des
vaccins protègent aussi des variants et
en ou d'accident en évitant la
propagation de ces variants on pourra
aussi éviter la
la propagation de nouvelles variantes
qui barrerait parce qu'elle m'est arrivé
c'est inévitable mais là encore il à la
question c'est de savoir si les vaccins
sont justement efficace face à ces
variants suffisamment efficace en tout
cas comment la population réagit en
italie alors je dois dire que les
italiens se font vacciner
surtout pour parce que on sait que même
si les vallées vaccin ne protège pas
faim ne limite pas les pontages donc on
peut être content âgées il diminue les
effets de la maladie donc c'est ça qui
est important c'est aussi d'éviter la
pression sur les hôpitaux donc temps que
les vaccins nous protège la maladie et
nous empêche de tomber malade et de
terminer 2e de finir en hospitalisation
dans des
pandore dans des champs intensif c'est
ça l'important
s'agissant du variant indien il ya deux
cas recensés dans la région de venise
l'italie qui a fermé ses frontières avec
l'inde ça c'est une bonne décision selon
vous oui c'est vrai que la fermeture des
frontières et beat le déplacement des
personnes et le 8 la propagation du
virus
maintenant c'est vrai que voilà avec les
nouveaux variants il faut quand même
faire attention il faut quand même
maintenir les gestes barrière ça ne
change pas c'est toujours ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on fait depuis un an donc même
s'il ya de nouveaux variants il faut
continuer comme ça il faut continuer
avec les gestes barrières qu'on a
toujours fait merci beaucoup à vous que
mes liens genovesi je rappelle que vous
êtes médecin à milan merci à vous
d'avoir un chef à indépendantistes
sahraouis à l'origine un début de crise
diplomatique entre rabat et madrid
en tout cas à ce que le gouvernement
marocain a laissé sous-entendre après la
prise en charge médicale en espagne de
brahim ghali
ce dernier est en effet le leader du
front polisario qui milite pour
l'indépendance du sahara occidental une
ancienne colonie espagnole revendiqué
par le royaume marocain on voit cela
avec florian lambert l'espagne s'attire
les foudres du maroc après avoir
accueilli et pris en charge le chef des
indépendantistes sahraouis brahim ghali
après sa contamination commis 19
dans une conférence de presse
exceptionnelle madrid assure que cette
décision ne devrait pas affecter les
bonnes relations entre le maroc et
l'espagne
cela n'empêche pas et ne perturbent pas
les excellentes relations que l'espagne
avec le maroc après un cessez le feu
depuis presque trente ans les hostilités
ont repris à la mi novembre 2020
le front polisario et le royaume du
maroc s'affrontent de nouveau sahara
occidental depuis son élection en 2016 à
la tête du polisario de la république
arabe sahraouie démocratique
galy continue de militer pour
l'indépendance de ce territoire situé au
sud du maroc
la chef de la diplomatie espagnole
arantxa gonzalez la ja évoque des
raisons humanitaires pour justifier
cette prise en charge médicale du chef
indépendantiste sahraoui on en parle
tout de suite avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir à vous merci à d'être avec nous
sur rt france quel est l'état des
relations entre l'espagne et le maroc
aujourd'hui ces relations sont très
bonnes en tout cas jusqu'à la semaine
dernière et je pense qu'elles
reviendront très rapidement pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il ya un socle
économique très solide
l'espagne est le premier client est le
premier fournisseur du maroc de terriers
devant devant la france devant
l'allemagne et les relations bilatérales
sont assez équilibrés sur le plan
commercial il ya une assez bonne
complémentarité et puis parce que les
entreprises espagnoles investissent au
maroc notamment dans le secteur des
services du tourisme dans le domaine des
infrastructures des transports notamment
et que environ 800 entreprises
espagnoles sont implantées au maroc
la deuxième raison c'est que depuis les
attentats d'atocha à madrid
le maroc se prête à une très forte
coopération avec l'espagne dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
et puis cette coopération a été étendu
à la lutte contre les trafics de drogue
contre aussi les trafics d'êtres humains
et au final est finalement depuis aussi
plusieurs années la france est la part
dont l'espagne et le maroc comme un père
pour limiter les migrants et les trafics
de l'étoile et les migrants qui arrive
quelquefois du sahel et qui passe par
les canaries ou par ceuta et mellila et
avec l'aide de frontex
les marocains et les espagnols s'efforce
de limiter ou d'empêcher ces courants de
migration illégale
il ya donc une coopération très
diversifié à telle enseigne que les
ministres de l'intérieur se voit presque
tous les mois se parle tout le temps sur
tous ces sujets et que le roi d'espagne
a fait une visite d'état il ya deux ans
qui s'est terminée quelques ce qui s'est
traduit quelques semaines plus tard par
la conclusion d'un traité de partenariat
qualifié de multi dimensionnelle puisque
comme je voulais dit il s'adresse à la
fois à l'économie ils s'appliquent à la
lutte contre le terrorisme est également
contre l'immigration clandestine
alors cette affaire brahim ghali est-ce
qu'elle va entacher justement les
relations entre les deux royaumes et
vous dire c'est le gouvernement algérien
qui a demandé aux espagnols de de
prendre le chef du polisario puisque les
algériens ne parvenait plus à traiter
sont que vit 19 apparemment très grave
ils ont d'abord demandé à l'allemagne
puisque le président algérien a été
traité dans un hôpital allemand les
allemands ont plutôt décliner et par
conséquent pour des raisons humanitaires
je crois en effet l'espagne a accepté de
prendre seul le chef du polisario pour
le traité dans un hôpital près de
saragosse
ça peut permettre aussi peut-être
d'avoir des conversations avec lui et
peut-être aussi de voir dans quelle
mesure il est possible d'avoir des
négociations ultérieures avec le
polisario
donc je pense que la crise avec le maroc
est provisoire elle est pour quelques
périodes mais d'ici quelques semaines le
chef du polisario va retourner en
algérie où il vit avec son avec son
gouvernement en exil dans là où sont les
exilés sahraouis dans le camps de
tindouf et que et bien les bonnes
relations reprendront par la suite est
ce qui est une solution in fine est
justement à cette question du sahara
occidental
goûtez le rapport de forces est modifié
il s'est modifié parce que le maroc a
connu une croissance économique
importante que le maroc est devenu un
acteur économique important que il joue
le rôle un peu d'intermédiaire entre
l'espagne et l'afrique que l'espagne à
réintégrer l'union africaine qui elle
avait quitté lorsque les sahraouis
avaient été admis il ya un certain
nombre d'années par conséquent on voit
bien que le rapport de force s'est
modifié et puis le précédent président
des états unis a fait une déclaration
importante qui a un petit peu à l'armée
le secrétaire-général des nations unies
lorsqu'il a dit à la fin de l'année
dernière que le sahara occidental
appartenait évidemment au maroc
alors il l'a fait dans un contexte un
peu particulier c'était pour achever
leur achève le le rapprochement entre le
maroc et israël
d'ailleurs on constate que dans les
combats qui ont eu lieu il ya peu de
temps au début de ce mois comme vous été
mentionné dans votre reportage est bien
le maroc a utilisé des drones d'origine
israélienne
par conséquent le rapport de force s'est
modifié et aujourd'hui le problème est
plutôt pour l'espagne de convaincre le
de convaincre les sahraouis et le
convoque peut-être les algériens aussi
d'accepter une solution négociée qui
serait sans doute une autonomie du
sahara occidental dans un cadre marocain
sous la souveraineté marocaine
merci beaucoup à vous claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales et dans le reste de
l'actualité à jérusalem maintenant le
calme à est de retour après plusieurs
nuits de violence entre la police
israélienne et les manifestants
palestiniens la raison de ces
échauffourées l'interdiction pour des
raisons sanitaires d'approcher la porte
de damas un lieu de rassemblement à des
musulmans en cette période de ramadan
on voit cela avec nicolas petit
des dizaines de palestiniens qui
applaudissent et chante en guise de
célébration dimanche soir la circulation
sur cette promenade donnant accès à
l'esplanade des mosquées a de nouveau
été autorisés une levée des barrières
vécu comme un juste retour des choses
par ses fidèles palestiniens depuis le
début du ramadan israël a décidé
d'imposer nouvelle situation autour de
la porte de damas cette nouvelle réalité
ne correspond pas aux besoins des
habitants de la ville en tant que
musulmans nous avons l'habitude de nous
asseoir à côté de la porte de damas
après les prières et les forces
d'occupation ont décidé de fermer cet
espace les palestiniens ont récupéré un
de leurs droits l'histoire ici à la
porte de damas n'est pas le retrait de
ces barrières mais la raison pour
laquelle les israéliens avaient mis ces
barrières en premier lieu maintenant les
palestiniens peuvent se déplacer
librement dans cette zone et se
retrouvait à un endroit où il est
peut-être en raison de l'épidémie
cody 19 les forces de l'ordre
israéliennes avaient récemment fermé
l'accès est interdit tout rassemblement
sur cette promenade provoquant la colère
des palestiniens
habitués à se réunir près de la porte de
damas durant le ramadan jeudi soir les
tension était encore montée d'un cran
lorsque ces derniers ont voulu s'opposer
à une manifestation de juifs de droite
radicale à proximité s'en étaient
suivies des heurts particulièrement
violents avec la police israélienne
faisant plus d'une centaine de blessés
parmi les palestiniens
l dimanche quelques heures avant la
levée des restrictions et des centaines
de manifestants avaient décidé de se
rassembler à gaza pour apporter leur
soutien aux palestiniens
aujourd'hui nous sommes sortis avec
cette grande foule pour déclarer notre
soutien aux jeunes de la ville de
jérusalem qui font face à l'occupation
ou evo qui s'opposent aux israéliens qui
détruisent la ville de jérusalem nous le
jérusalem ne faisons qu'un face à
l'occupant nous envoyons un message à
l'ennemi sioniste et au sanctifié la
jeunesse le peuple et la résistance de
gaza sont avec vous et ne vous lâcherons
pas nous serons toujours en première
ligne et nous donnons nos âmes et notre
sang sacrifices pour jérusalem et la
mosquée al-aqsa
bien que la police israélienne et
dimanche soir disperser la foule et
procéder à une arrestation après que des
drapeaux palestiniens ont été brandis à
la suite de la levée des restrictions
sur l'esplanade des mosquées
les tensions semblent être retombés un
retour au calme qui reste fragile
restez avec nous pour la seconde partie
de l'émission nous parlerons de la
plainte contre michel blanc terre
déposée par un millier d'étudiants en
compte le maintien
les examens de fin d'année en présentiel
malgré la crise sanitaire et puis nous
nous intéresserons varions indien du
colis de 19 qui inquiète l'europe à
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous appelons des
pratiques professionnelles protectrice
la justice à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative en sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï chez les gens
qui s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des vignes ont aujourd'hui on a
une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec les gens vont manger un autre
combat on na vi qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 26 avril la colère des étudiants
en bts mille d'entre eux ont déposé
plainte contre jean-michel blanquer
dominique vidal devant la cour de
justice de la république les ministres
de l'éducation nationale et de
l'enseignement supérieur sont accusés d'
exposer les étudiants un risque de
contamination par le coït 19 en cause le
maintien des examens de fin d'année en
présentiel malgré la crise sanitaire les
étudiants réclament un contrôle continu
le triple variant indien de plus en plus
redoutée alors que l'épidémie paraît
hors de contrôle en inde avec un record
de près de 350 mille 15 24 heures
recensés ce dimanche plusieurs
contaminations déjà été constatées sur
le sol européen
dernière en date deux cas aujourd'hui
dans la région de venise en italie cette
mutation
elle serait plus contagieuse selon
certains experts la résistance aux
vaccins aux questions
[Musique]
il s'exprime rarement dans la presse 20
généraux à la retraite ont signé une
tribune dans l'hebdomadaire valeurs
actuelles à la semaine dernière dans
cette lettre ouverte il appelle au
patriotisme et à retrouver je cite
l'honneur de nos gouvernants un texte
qui scandalise une partie de la classe
politique
de son côté marine le pen lors dans la
main nous en débattrons dans cette
émission
[Musique]
les enfants de maternelle et de primaire
sont de retour ce matin sur les bancs de
l'école après trois semaines d'absence
une semaine de cours à distance et de
vacances et une rentrée organisée avec
un protocole sanitaire stricte quatre
cent mille tests salivaires sont prêts à
être utilisés et des fermetures de
classes sont prévues dès le premier cas
positif
le chef de l'état et le ministre de
l'éducation a été en déplacement dans
une école aujourd'hui pour échanger avec
les élèves et enseignants objectif
premier les remercier de leur engagement
mais aussi aborder avec eux le cadre
sanitaire du côté des collèges et des
lycées
la rentrée se fera en distance yale et
on parlait à l'instant de jean michel
blanquer une plainte le visant ainsi que
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
a été déposée ce week-end selon une
information du jdd en cause le maintien
des examens de bts en présentiel est les
deux ministres sont accusés d' exposer
les étudiants un risque de contamination
qu'ovide 19
les précisions d'estelle fâchent ils
réclamaient une évaluation en contrôle
continu ce sera en fin de compte à un
examen final en présentiel pour les
étudiants en bts lors d'un point presse
le 22 avril dernier le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a tranché après le
doubs mais les examens seront assurés en
présence mais avec des conditions
sanitaires strictes
il en va de même aussi pour les
étudiants de bts c'est un sujet dont
j'ai été beaucoup saisie je voudrais
m'adresser le tout particulièrement
puisque j'ai bien compris qu'il y avait
parfois un malaise pour certains d'entre
eux qui se sentent même parfois mal
préparé du fait des circonstances et je
voudrais dire donc quelques éléments sur
ce point le premier c'est que bien
entendu nous sommes capables de prendre
en considération les situations
particulières
chaque bts est un cas particulier
frédéric vidal appui annoncé la semaine
dernière que nous faisions une session
de rattrapage
cela signifie donc que les épreuves de
bts prévu au mois de mai auront lieu
mais que pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas
y aller parce qu'ils seraient malades ou
qui échoueraient à cette épreuve il aura
une session de rattrapage au début du
mois de juillet cette session de
rattrapage consistera en euros
et c'est euro pourront être préparés
spécifiquement en mai et juin
nous dégageons les moyens
supplémentaires pour qu'il y ait un
impact compagne mans personnalisé de
chaque élève
jean michel blanc coeur l'a assuré il
s'agit pour l'exécutif de garantie à la
valeur des diplômes et d'offrir aux
étudiants le meilleur entraînement pour
les examens à venir
mais certains ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille ce sera donc à la justice
de trancher le 23 avril un millier
d'étudiants et plusieurs associations
ont décidé de porter plainte contre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
leur avocat l'a annoncé dans un
communiqué 400 personnes dans une même
salle
pendant que les collèges lycées et
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur sont fermés en raison de la
situation sanitaire
cela est incompréhensible et expose ses
jeunes non seulement un risque de
contamination par le coït 19 mais aussi
à des risques psychologiques
parmi les autres actions intentées en
recours en référé a été déposé auprès du
conseil d'état
l'avocat qui a aussi précisé qu'une
plainte avait été déposée devant la cour
de justice de la république contre les
deux ministres pour je cite mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui
objectif faire annuler les examens en
présentiel et mettre les ministres
devant leurs responsabilités nous dit le
communiqué jean michel blanquer était
l'invité du grand jury sur lci ce
dimanche réponse les plaintes n'ont pas
lieu d'être a affirmé le ministre de
l'éducation nationale reste à savoir si
cet avis sera partagée par les
magistrats
et on en parle tout de suite avec
jackass miss et les délégués de l'union
nationale inter universitaire
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord sur cette
plainte des étudiants en bts contre jean
michel blanquer
qu'en pensez vous en réalité qu'est ce
que les étudiants dénoncent ils
dénoncent l'amateurisme la déconnexion
et l'incompétence totale de ce
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire
ce que nous à l'union dénonce depuis
maintenant et c'est malheureux de le
dire le début de la crise c'est-à-dire
depuis un an et demi quand lors du
premier confinement nous demandions au
gouvernement aux ministres de
l'éducation nationale et la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de préparer la
rentrée 2020 pas qu'on savait
stratégique puisque les établissements
avaient été fermés durant une une longue
période de temps
quand nous demandions des examens bien
construit et bien organisés au premier
semestre pour sanctionner le travail de
ses étudiants en décembre on a bien
compris que ce n'était pas l'objectif du
gouvernement
et quand dans ce mois même mois de
décembre la ministre nous annonce un
retour en présentiel au mois de janvier
et que la première conférence de presse
de notre cher premier ministre jean
castex tu es bien ne mentionne pas une
seule fois le mot étudiants et ne
mentionne même pas une seule fois le la
jeunesse de france
eh bien on se rend bien compte que ce
n'est pas une priorité que la jeunesse
est que les étudiants n'est pas une
priorité pour le gouvernement est en
fête
et encore une fois qu'est ce que dénonce
et étudiants tout simplement ils
dénoncent les annonces à la petite
semaine
deux de ces deux de ses ministres qui ne
comprennent pas la détresse des
étudiants est aujourd'hui on se rend
bien compte que même et on va en parler
j'espère sur l'organisation de ce second
semestre ses examens nombreux sont les
étudiants haineux et ne parlons pas
seulement du bts nombreux sont les
étudiants qui ne savent toujours pas
comment ils passeront leurs examens en
distance yens ou en présentiel
telle est la question mais c'est aussi
compliqué pour le gouvernement lorsqu'il
n'y a pas de présentiel et bien ça ne
fait pas l'unanimité quand il y a
justement des présentiel il ya encore il
n'ya pas de satisfaction comment vous
interprétez le fond justement de cette
décision de jean michel blanquer
concernant ces
ces étudiants en bts marne le maintenir
leurs examens en présentiel
mais aujourd'hui encore une fois on
demande au ministre de tout simplement
comprendre l'importance de la détresse
de ces étudiants et l'importance de
l'incompréhension qui la compréhension
qu'ils ont de leur gestion de la crise
cette gestion qui est catastrophique
disons le aujourd'hui toutes les
problématiques liées à cela et on
entendait le ministre en parler sur la
valeur du diplôme sur l'insertion
professionnelle sur la réussite de ses
étudiants on n'a pas l'impression que ça
soit la priorité du gouvernement quand
on voit les chiffres ils sont alarmants
quand on voit que le taux de 2,2 de
réorientation des étudiants a augmenté
de 5% cela prouve bien d'une que le
diplôme du bac a été malheureusement
bien dégradée l'année dernière et qu'il
y a eu beaucoup trop d'étudiants qui
sont rentrés dans cet ordre
d'enseignement supérieur et ce nombre
est largement trop trop trop élevé quand
on voit que sur toute l'année 2020 près
de 55 % des diplômés de master 2 c'est à
dire 50 d'enseignement supérieur n'ont
pas trouvé de boulot et non pas trouvé
ne se sont pas inséré
professionnellement justement au bout de
six mois on voit bien qu'il ya des
réelles problématiques que le
gouvernement même nos propres raconte et
nous on l'a fait on a fait le travail
parlementaire pour lutter contre la
précarité étudiante à nous des
propositions de loi sont déposées en ce
moment-même sénat notamment et que
faut-il faire il faut annuler les
examens présentiel c'est réaliste il il
faut comprendre d'une la détresse des
étudiants et comprendre que leur
insertion professionnelle est en jeu et
quand on voit que les étudiants
n'arrivent pas à voir plus loin que leur
bout de leur nez
il faut comprendre que ces étudiants
veulent simplement appréhender leur
avenir et nous on demande clairement au
ministre vous me demandez vous me posez
la question dans le clairement ministre
il y à ce sujet des examens mais il y a
aussi clairement le sujet de la rentrée
prochaine
et comme nous l'avions fait lors du
premier confinement demande et nous
demandons aujourd'hui au ministère de
comprendre que la rentrée prochaine va
être très stratégique et qui va falloir
la faire en présentiel
donc mais justement vous évoquez la
dévalorisation du diplôme pour éviter
d'aller jusque là cette conséquence qui
est dramatique pour les étudiants et
leur avenir
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et bien
clairement c'est ce qu'on demande depuis
maintenant janvier puisqu'on avions nous
avions nous étions rendus compte que
c'était en janvier qu'on a vu que nous
avions été déçu tout simplement sur le
retour en présentiel
il faut il faut un retour présentiel
avec en fait il faut écouter les vous
savez les présidents d'université qui
sont sur le terrain et qui connaissent
la réalité du terrain et quand vous avez
l'ensemble des présidents ou en tout cas
l'immense majorité des présidents
d'université qui vous disent que et
qu'il le dise le ministère que près de
preuve que la capacité d'accueil que la
jauge d'accueil qui est aujourd'hui
bloqué à 20%
peut-être augmenter à 50% eh bien il
faut écouter et comme nous nous nous
voyons la ministre vidal se rendre
compte seulement maintenant que
effectivement cette jauge des 50% des
capacités d'accueil peuvent être
attendre dans les conditions sanitaires
comme le dit les présidents d'université
comme demande lui nie depuis très
longtemps depuis maintenant quelques
mois et est bien le dit qu'on va le
faire pour me mets mi juin et madame la
ministre mi-mai mi juin
vous êtes complètement déconnecté de la
réalité il n'ya plus aucun étudiants sur
les campus
donc aujourd'hui on se rend encore une
fois compte que le gouvernement que ça
soit la ministre vidalou houleux où
monsieur bleu blanc coeur qu'ils sont
déconnectés de la réalité et quand on
voit une madame vidal qui nous dit que
la jauge des 50% va enfin être atteinte
mais pour seulement mi mai et mi juin
eh bien on voit bien qu'elle est
complètement déconnecté et que
maintenant la grande question c'est la
rentrée prochaine et qu'il faut s'y
préparer dès maintenant et en plus du
risque de contamination l'avocat du
collectif 1 d'étudiants qui portent
plainte m d'ils et diot pointe une
fatigue morale une détresse chez ces
jeunes
est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment qu'ils sont
entendus que le ministère de l'éducation
prend suffisamment en compte ce facteur
non absolument pas absolument pas je
porte que et puis je les dis il ya il y
à un moment où vous savez quand il y à
cet étudiant sur dix qui ont qui se
sentent qu'ils sentent leur santé
mentale dégradé quand vous avez près
d'un quart des étudiants qui ont déjà eu
des pensées suicidaires et tout cela lié
au décrochage bien évidemment vous savez
quand madame vidal se targue de des
statistiques de 90% de taux de présence
aux examens pour le premier semestre
il faut bien que madame vidal
comprennent que rendre une copie blanche
ce n'est pas une preuve de réussite est
un gage de réussite c'est à dire que
dans ces 90 % qu'elle de ce fameux
chiffres qu'elle qu'elle se vante de de
dire il y a des copies blanche est donc
ce n'est absolument pas une réussite
et d'ailleurs on nous demandons toujours
à la ministre le taux de réussite qu'il
faudrait les statistiques de taux de
réussite qu'il faudrait avoir pour ses
promesses mais ce pour bien comprendre
que le distanti elle est bien aggrave la
qualité de notre formation dégrade la
valeur de notre diplôme et amène au
décrochage qui malheureusement ensuite
tout est lié
dégrade aussi l'insertion
professionnelle des favorise l'insertion
professionnelle de tous nos jeunes donc
il y a vraiment tous ces objectifs là
toutes ces statistiques malheureuse là
qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en compte
et avoir encore une fois l'idée de la
rentrée prochaine en ligne de en ligne
de mire et justement très bien et nous
essayer de la prétentaine que
demandez-vous en vue de la rentrée
prochaine rapidement et bien tout ça
tout simplement une rentrée en
présentiel dans les conditions
sanitaires mais une rentrée en
présentiel ou les étudiants pourront
retrouver les bancs de leurs de leurs
facultés retrouver le lien social qui
leur a tant manqué depuis depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et pouvoir tout
simplement vivre
retrouvez aussi les jobs les stages
qu'ils avaient perdue depuis depuis un
an et demi est tout simplement vivre
leur vie étudiante comme il l'avait
comme il l'avait souhaité vous savez que
ce soit les premières années où les
deuxièmes années il faut bien comprendre
que tous les élans et les l2
et les premières et l'ensemble des 1er
et 2e dan et de l'ensemble de
l'enseignement supérieur français n'ont
pas connu une année universitaire normal
complète et donc aujourd'hui il faut
clairement quand on nous parle d'un
impact de la crise sanitaire qui vont
qui va perdurer et bien là nous ont dit
que les étudiants ne vont pas perdurer
comme ça longtemps et donc que la
rentrée universitaire 2021 va être
largement stratégique et que le
ministère doit s'y préparer dès
maintenant pour qu'elle se fasse au
maximum en présentiel une rentrée
universitaire qui sera probablement
conditionné par à l'avancé donc de la
campagne vaccinale merci à vous jacques
smith je rappelle que vous êtes délégué
de l'union nationale inter-universitaire
l'inde fortement touchée par un nouveau
variant du colis 19 celui ci soulève de
plus en plus d'inquiétudes à l'étranger
en europe
les autorités sanitaires redoutent ce
variant indien particulièrement
transmissibles on voit cela avec robin
pu l tous les regards sont tournés vers
le variant indien alors que cette
mutation du coc vie 19 fait des ravages
en inde
l'europe recensé première contamination
plusieurs cars ont été découverts
notamment en belgique chez une vingtaine
d'étudiants indiens testé positif ayant
transité par l'aéroport roissy charles
de gaulle en tout ce sont au moins huit
pays du continent qui ont détecté ce
variant sur leur sol face à la menace
grandissante de cette nouvelle forme de
kovy 19 plusieurs états comme
l'allemagne ont classé l'inde comme zone
à haut risque afin de réduire fortement
les arrivées en provenance de ce
territoire pour ne pas mettre en danger
notre campagne de vaccination nous
devons nettement réduire le trafic de
voyageurs avec l'inde
seuls les citoyens de nationalité
allemande pourront voyager d'inde vers
l'allemagne
ils seront autorisés à voyager seulement
sur présentation d'un test négatif fait
peu de temps avant le vol et devront se
mettre en quarantaine pour 14 jours
immédiatement après leur arrivée cette
nouvelle forme de virus n'a pas encore
été détecté en métropole française mais
deux personnes ont été diagnostiquées
positive à ce variant en guadeloupe
l'exécutif a donc choisi d'appliquer la
quarantaine aux passagers en provenance
d'inde
même s'il est encore trop tôt pour se
prononcer sur sa dangerosité santé
publique france a indiqué avoir augmenté
sa vigilance
vis-à-vis du var et un indien une étude
est en cours pour déterminer sa
résistance aux vaccins en pleine
campagne de vaccination plusieurs
scientifiques français se veulent
rassurants avec des technologies
actuelles il serait possible de
fabriquer très rapidement de nouvelles
cibles vaccinale on pourrait tout à fait
imaginer qu'une nouvelle injection des
vaccins un rappel en quelque sorte
puisse justement aider à combattre ce
variant si jamais il devait devenir
majoritaire en france pour le moment
la menace de l'arrivée de ce nouveau
variant ne perturbe pas les calendriers
de déconfinement des états européens
on en parle tout de suite avec vincent
maréchal et professeur de virologie à la
sorbonne universités bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous l'inde qui
enregistre donc car enregistré dimanche
350 milles qu'un en 24 heures c'est un
chiffre c'est vrai très impressionnant
mais si on compare aux 1,3 milliard
d'habitants que compte le pays c'est
finalement peu oui tout à fait alors bon
ça reste des chiffres inquiétants mais
jojo j'entends dire que comme mario et
c'est à juste titre nous préoccupe
il faut comprendre aussi que l'inde est
un pays densément peuplées c'est un pays
dans lequel elles et pour différentes
raisons notamment parce qu'ils avaient
des rassemblements religieux très
important ces dernières semaines des
rassemblements liés également à des
processus électoraux qui sont en cours
en inde
eh bien on en a on a favorisé on a créé
les conditions d'une circulation virale
très active alors peut-être qu'elle est
amplifié par les propriétés de ce
variant qui est encore à l'étude dont on
sait assez peu de choses mais très
clairement on a affaire à des situations
particulières qui ont favorisé la
circulation du virus le bal - sur un
territoire qui étaient déjà exposées
depuis depuis un an
alors comment est ce qu'il faut faire
justement pour éviter que ce variant
indien ne se propage un peu partout on
avec 20 étudiants indiens ont été testés
positifs à ce variant alors arrivée à
bruxelles
après avoir justement transité par
roissy les contrôles aux frontières il
faut les renforcer
alors je dirais que le problème il est
pas spécifique aux variants indien
l'idée de toute façon de limiter
l'import sur le territoire national et
sur le territoire européen
plus généralement de variants qui
auraient des propriétés d'échappement au
vaccin par exemple ou des propriétés de
virulence ou de contagiosité accrue donc
les mesures que l'on prend de toute
façon sont des mesures qui visent à
limiter au maximum l'introduction de ces
nouvelles formes
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas 36 solutions
la seule façon de le faire c'est
effectivement lors de vols
particulièrement à risque de tester les
passagers et surtout de mettre en place
qui a toujours été un problème en france
des procédures d'isolement des
procédures de quarantaine d'environ 10
jours de manière à limiter la
circulation ces gens sur le territoire
tant qu'ils sont dans une période où
potentiellement elles peuvent contaminer
leur entourage
donc il est absolument essentiel mais
c'est vrai autant pour ce variant que
pour les autres de mettre en place des
procédures de contrôle aux frontières et
idéalement il faut avoir une
concertation européenne sur cette
question alors justement la restriction
des vols le gouvernement l'a annoncé
avec cet isolement obligatoire de 10
jours pour les vols venant d'inde mais
aussi d'autres pays le brésil le chili
l'argentine encore l'afrique du sud
est ce que ray véritablement c'est
suffisant alors suffisant ou le sait
toujours sur la durée ce qui est clair
c'est que de ne rien faire favorisera la
réintroduction répétées de variants qui
pose des problèmes
si on interdit si on contrôle en tout
cas les vols en provenance du brésil
c'est pas pour le vario indien en
l'occurrence c'est bien parce que au
brésil circuit l'invariant qu'on connaît
maintenant depuis quelques mois dont on
sait qu'il est problématique même de la
même façon le variant qui circulent en
afrique du sud et en variants
problématique parce qu'il semble que les
réponses immunitaires dirigée contre ces
virus soit moins importante soit moins
efficace donc en tout état de cause
c'est une mesure qu'il est important de
prendre aujourd'hui le temps que les
processus de l'acsi nation se met en
place sur le territoire européen que les
populations soient mieux protégés il
faut effectivement pour le des mesures
ça en fait partie
bien sûr mais est-ce qu'il faut
véritablement s'inquiéter parce que vous
parlez du variant brésilien on sait que
le conseil scientifique a prévenu alerté
face à une vague importante d'ici l'été
ça veut dire que après le
le variant indien pourrait aussi
provoquer le même effet compenser on
peut c'est très difficile d'anticiper ce
qui va se passer 1
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il faut d'abord
caractériser les propriétés de ces
variants on n'aura pas tout à fait la
même situation avec des variants qui
vont être bloqués par la réponse
immunitaire naturel ou vaccinale et des
variants qui pourraient échapper donc la
question se pose il ya un autre
phénomène qui intervient le variant sud
africain aujourd'hui aux alentours de 4
à 5 % des cas détectés en moyenne mais
probablement aussi parce que le variant
britannique et variant 2001 aujourd'hui
empêche ce variant de s'implanter sur le
territoire faut pas oublier qu'à une
compétition entre les virus et un
instant donné
encore une fois il faut à la fois limité
la circulation du virus est limité la
circulation du virus et mettre en place
des procédures de dépistage et
d'isolement efficace en attendant de
déployer de façon tout à fait efficace
une campagne de vaccination qui
protégera l'essentiel de la population à
risque j'aurais peut-être dû commencer
par là que c'est ont finalement de ce
variant indien il est plus transmissible
et ce qu'il est plus dangereux que le
variant britanniques ou aux brésiliens
c'est bien car c'est très beau c'est
très tôt pour le dire ce qu'on déduit on
le déduit des mutations qui ont été
détectés sur ce variant il ya deux
mutations qui sont un peu problématique
lune parce qu'on l'avait étudié et
identifié sur une forme qui avait sévi
en californie il ya quelques mois et
l'eau parce que c'est une des mutations
préoccupante du variant sud africain on
se retrouve par un phénomène qu'on
appelle une convergence évolutive avec
la présence de ces deux mutations un peu
problématique sur le sur le même virus
et de plex concept ces mutations dans
d'autres contextes et qu'elles limitent
la réponse immunitaire
donc ça c'est un facteur nous préoccupe
beaucoup et on sait également que
certaines de ces mutations sont associés
à une contagiosité plus importante
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui en revanche
c'est si ces variants sont plus
virulents et au globalement on se
conseille aussi de ces variants c'est
principalement ce qu'on déduit d'études
qui ont peut-être fait ailleurs on n'a
pas encore d'études poussées sur le
territoire indien qui permettrait de
qualifié potentiel de ce virus mais on
sait qu'il est déjà très présent je
crois qu'on estime dans certaines études
qu'il est déjà présent à plus de 30%
dans les souches qui sont analysés non
mais c'est vrai qu'à vous
la gestion de la crise sanitaire en inde
par exemple là on voit que les cas
explose on pouvait imaginer qu'il y
avait une immunité quand même importante
visiblement ce n'est pas le cas en inde
on peut l'affirmer c'est toujours c'est
toujours très compliqué parce que
d'abord il ya une première vague mais
qui a été relativement bien contrôlé il
ya quasiment un an il y avait une
première vague d'épidémie que là que
l'inde pour différentes raisons avaient
réussi à voir régresser assez rapidement
le problème aujourd'hui de l'inde sait
qu'après cette première vague ya une
confiance très importante probablement
des politiques et aussi les gens qui
font que très vite l'inde a rope un
rythme de vie normal sans mesures
particulières de contrôle de l'infection
et puis des événements qu'on avait
qu'évoquer des grands rassemblements
pour des élections des grands
rassemblements religieux ont facilité la
circulation du virus alors dans certains
territoires en inde notamment dans la
région de new delhi on imagine que près
de 50% de la population a été exposé au
virus
maintenant la question qui se pose c'est
effectivement est ce que ces variants
sont capables de réaffecter les gens qui
auraient déjà rencontré le virus il ya
plusieurs mois aujourd'hui on n'a pas
les informations qui permettent de
l'affirmer comme on n'a pas non plus
d'informations qui permet de dire que le
variant est plus virulent ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il ya une vague épidémique
majeur et plus le virus circule plus il
ya des cas et puis à des cas
malheureusement
puis il ya des cas graves merci beaucoup
à vous vincent maréchal je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de virologie à la
sorbonne universités 6 merci bonsoir
ailleurs dans le monde en argentine la
situation sanitaire a également toujours
tendues avec plus de soixante mille
morts alors que pour tenter d'enrayer
l'épidémie le président a pris de
nouvelles mesures parmi elles la
fermeture des écoles une décision
d'ailleurs très contesté par la
population
on voit cela avec grace taille à des
pupitres des professeurs et des élèves
plus studieux que jamais en plein centre
ville de buenos aires faire la classe en
plein air c'est l'action imaginé par
jimena blanco l'organisatrice pour
sensibiliser l'opinion publique suite à
la décision gouvernementale de fermer
les écoles pour enrayer l'épidémie de
kovy de 19 cela a été un seau d'eau
froide pour nous tous nous lisons les
médias nous sommes informés
donc nous attendions des mesures
mais la dernière à laquelle nous nous
attendions était la fermeture des écoles
parce que nous avions compris que nous
étions parvenus à un accord en tant que
société que les écoles seraient la
dernière option déjà plus d'un an que
ces élèves n'ont pas eu de cours en
présentiel un drame pour les familles
les organisateurs ont lancé une pétition
demandant la suspension du décret
présidentiel imposant la fermeture des
écoles pendant deux semaines le document
a recueilli 28 mille cinq cents
signatures
je pense que nous ne devons pas avoir de
jugement nous devons être informés et
avoir des critères donc un an et demi de
fermeture d'école et 60% de pauvreté
infantile
il n'y a pas de place pour une autre
année de fermeture d'école nous devons
tous gérer la pandémie
malgré l'opposition le gouvernement est
formel avec 26000 contamination pour la
seule journée de mercredi
le président estime ne pas avoir d'autre
choix quand j'ai décidé de ne pas
poursuivre les cours c'est parce que
j'avais vu les chiffres croissants des
vingt ou trente derniers jours
la contagiosité des enfants du
nouveau-né jusqu'à 19 ans a augmenté de
plus de 200%
que dois-je faire devrais-je fermer les
yeux doivent regarder les enquêtes que
dois-je faire
avec une population de 45 millions
d'habitants l'argentine a dépassé
mercredi les deux millions sept cent
mille cas en plus de la fermeture des
écoles
un couvre-feu de 20h à 6h du matin la
suspension de toute pratique religieuse
sociale et sportive ont également été
imposées dans la capitale buenos aires
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la tribune de vin généraux à la
retraite dans valeurs actuelles
lance le délitement dont serait frappé
l'état une lettre ouverte qui scandalise
une partie de la classe politique et
puis nous parlerons du tchad où les
militaires au pouvoir refuse les
négociations avec les rebelles
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la nouvelle menace qui pèse sur
l'industrie une pénurie de matières
premières vous avez un phénomène qui est
le phénomène qui a fait monter tous les
actifs et qui ne sont pas forcément
d'actifs industriels des métaux ou autre
qui est l'inondation par les banques
centrales de monnaie il cette inondation
par les banques centrales de monnaie a
fait tout simplement grimper les prix
vous avez quand même à court terme un
équilibre dynamique entre l'offre et la
demande et qui fait qu'avec le kobe de
19 mai les prix des matières premières
se sont d'abord effondrée c'était le cas
sur le pétrole et que l'on à une
entreprise notamment parce qu'il ya un
pays qui est moins touchée que les
autres qui est le seul pays qui a fait
de la croissance économique
officiellement en dominant qui est la
chine aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
gesticulations en disant oh là là on va
manquer de telle ou telle matière
première que ça va relancer les choses
et que ça va permettre aux entreprises
de rouvrir
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
un certain regain de confiance est rompu
entre les politiques et les experts même
les citoyens on est une société qui est
totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et notre étude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas le confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde vit
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france et vous
nous rejoignez 21h30 heure française
c'est la polémique politique du moment
mercredi dernier l'hebdomadaire de
droite valeurs actuelles a publié une
tribune appelant emmanuel macron à
défendre le patriotisme en france une
lettre lancé par un ancien officier de
carrière et signée par plusieurs
militaires qui entendent dénoncer les
dangers qui menacent le pays un certain
anti racisme par exemple ou encore
l'islamisme et les hordes de banlieue
fin de citation de quoi faire vivement à
réagir l'ensemble de la classe politique
jusque dans les rangs même du
gouvernement explications en images dans
une lettre ouverte publiée sous forme de
tribune par l'hebdomadaire valeurs
actuelles mercredi 21 avril
une vingtaine d'anciens généraux appelle
au retour de l'honneur et du devoir au
sein de la classe politique
la missive entend dénoncer un délitement
de la france selon ses auteurs les
promoteurs d'un certain anti racisme
aurait en réalité pour objectif la
guerre raciale afin de voir se dissoudre
le pays
pointant entre autres périls l'islamisme
et les hordes de banlieue la tribune
appelle à réagir et n'hésite pas à
évoquer la menace d'une guerre civile
plusieurs figures de droite nationaliste
approuvent largement l'initiative
c'est le cas notamment de florian
philippot président des patriotes qui
n'a pas hésité à apporter son soutien
par le biais de son compte twitter
ou encore de marine le pen qui dans les
colonnes du même hebdomadaire valeurs
actuelles invitent les signataires à la
rejoindre en vue de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
de son côté la gauche est outré le
patron de la france insoumise jean luc
mélenchon qualifie le texte de factieux
point que le silence du président de la
république chef des armées et en appelle
à la justice
benoît hamon ancien ministre socialiste
relève la date de publication choisi 60
ans jour pour jour après le putsch
d'alger une tentative de coup d'état
militaire contre le président de gaulle
pour lui la menace est explicite
interpellé florence parly fini par
s'exprimer à son tour ce dimanche dans
une série de tweets
la ministre des armées évoque un texte
irresponsable dernier en date à réagir
au micro de france info ce lundi matin
la ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie hausse le ton et adresse une
pique sarcastique aux militaires une
tribune dont qui a fait beaucoup réagir
notamment dans la classe politique on en
parle tout de suite avec nos invités
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et nous sommes avec hello norbert
conseillère régionale fn en paca éric
bocquet sénateurs pcf du nord bonsoir à
vous merci d'être avec nous en direction
de france ce soir
d'abord peut-être un mot sur l'auteur et
les signataires de cette tribune
l'auteur c'est jean pierre fabre
bernadac est un ancien officier de
carrière il est responsable du blog
place d'armes c'est un site je suis allé
voir un site engagés pour la communauté
militaire qui rend qui entend valoriser
en tout cas les valeurs de l'armée
honneur patrie et fidélité avec lui donc
il ya des d'anciens généraux à la
retraite ou radiés pour de l'armée pour
leurs activités politiques
il y aurait aussi de milliers de
militaires un signataires de cette
tribune
il ya quand même beaucoup de questions
en tout cas sur leur activité leur
influence
un certain nombre de généraux d'entre
eux auraient été investis par le
rassemblement national lors de
différents scrutins locaux est ce que
vous confirmez et l'honneur baisse
écoutez moi ce que j'ai lu dans cette
tribune tout d'abord déjà je crois qu'il
faut aussi rendre hommage aux îles ne
pas insulter les militaires comme je
viens de le voir dans la lah pitoyable
phrase de la ministre déléguée de chargé
de l'industrie qui parle de généraux en
charentaises
j'évite d'être à s'excuser et est allé
voir le travail ici qu'il faut pour la
france sur le terrain donc pour revenir
au sujet qui nous intéresse est cette
tribune il s'agit d'anciens militaires
de militaires à la retraite qui ont tout
à fait le droit de s'exprimer sur la
situation de notre pays actuellement qui
est une situation effectivement qui est
appelée de fond examens d'adn est ce que
certains d'entre eux ce que ont déjà été
investis par le rassemblement national
pour des scrutins locaux et s'est
toutefois il est surtout de soi et de
l'été je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
précisément mais c'est toutefois il
l'était je ne vois pas où est la digue
où le souci
éric bocquet des généraux à la retraite
n'est peut-être actif dans la sphère
politique penser qu ils font quoi
écoutez je sens que c'est un événement
qu'il ne faut surtout pas minimiser
moi j'ai appris que l'armée c'était la
grande muette alors ces militaires sont
des citoyens bien sûr mais en tant que
militaire même s'ils sont en retraite
ils sont obligés à une obligation de
réserve qui devrait ne jamais quitter
leur esprit et ses déclarations ne
viennent pas à n'importe quel moment
on a cité la référence 10 21 avril 1961
le putsch des généraux d'alger
on peut aussi faire la référence oui
madame au 21 avril 2002 de sinistre
mémoire où jean marie le pen accéder au
second tour
voilà les eschois évident dans cette
opération de communication
on doit pas minimiser et puis il ya tout
un contexte qu'ils développent dans ce
pays on a assisté au sénat il ya
quelques semaines à des déclarations
absolument sidérant de la droite qui
savent s'apparenter clairement à celle
qu'on pouvait entendre la bouche du
rassemblement national
il ya des opérations dangereuses qui se
mène dans ce pays et tous les
républicains de quelque bord qu'ils
soient devraient être particulièrement
vigilant à ce moment difficile
elano rebelles vous répondez non alors
écoutez déjà je crois que c'est pas de
sinistrement le rassemblement national
n'est pas destinée se trouver moi mais
je rappellerai quand même que le parti
communiste etc et ses six millions de
morts en urss ont eu de sinistre mémoire
et ensuite les généraux si vous me
permettez de ses généraux et ses
militaires expose encore une fois une
situation qui est exposée une tribune de
bon sens voilà une situation factuelle
ou aujourd'hui effectivement en france
l'islamisme et le gauchisme ont des
liens étroits
je rappellerai g que l'attentât l'auteur
de l'attentât de rambouillet et celui
aussi ce jam lp laïque et de très
nombreuses publications de jean luc
mélenchon entre autres de yassine
belattar et de tout autre et d'autres
mouvances et officine d'extrême gauche
et que ce qu'il ne faut pas minimiser en
france c'est le risque du terrorisme
islamiste
c'est le risque des attentats c'est
cette situation qui est extrêmement
graves et nous sommes calmes à quelques
jours
houdain d'un attentat terrifiant qui a
vu une femme une mère de famille qui a
été donc illégales
est-ce que vous croyez que l'unique but
justement de cette tribune c'est de
dénoncer le terrorisme
éric bocquet le cas l'instant les
évoquer à l'instant les 60 ans jour pour
jour du putsch d'hergé ces essais c'est
là que cette ville a été lassé jacques
cette tribune a été publiée on sait que
le président emmanuel macron il a il
tente en fait une une d'initier une
réconciliation mémorielle franco
algérienne on sait aussi qu'il a
entretenu une relation houleuse avec les
armées au début de son mandat est ce que
c'est lui qui est visé le norvège parole
au nom de sa tribu non excisée mans je
crois ce qui est visé c'est la politique
qui est menée par emmanuel macron qui
est une politique qui nous firent qui ne
fait absolument rien c'est le laxisme
qui est visé et cette tribune ne parle
absolument pas de putsch de deux putschs
militaires
ça c'est une invention de monsieur
mélenchon ces tribus propose au
contraire parce qu'il ya de la phrase ou
tout à calmer le feu aux poudres c'est
il espère que l'intervention de nos
camarades active dans une mission de
protection des valeurs de protection des
valeurs et ce qu'a rappelé marine le pen
c'est qu'elle appelle justement ces
militaires et ses généraux nous les
appelons à rejoindre nos rangs pour une
bataille électorale
une bataille démocratique qui n'a rien à
voir avec un putsch c'est assez
lamentable quand même que jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon qui fait
les frais des siens il parle de ses
dirigeants lui monsieur monsieur
mélenchon parle de sédition sachant que
malgré tout il a quand même été lui il a
fait un tweet
je rappelle un seul tweet contre
l'attentât de rambouillet et quand je
trouve ça assez indécent après
l'attentât de rambouillet qui a encore
une fois cette mère de famille égorgé
par un idéaliste un clic et monsieur
mélenchon et 10 tweets pour des généraux
français et je rappelle que ses généraux
français ces soldats français protègent
et on protéger notre pays il le protège
aujourd'hui dans les opérations
extérieures par exemple au mali et nous
devons c'est un deux voies
de leur rendre hommage ils ont
parfaitement le droit de s'exprimer
ils sont à la retraite ils ont le droit
d'avoir également leur expression leur
liberté d'expression quel soir dans une
tribune où qu'elles soient politiques
effectivement eh bien ils sont la
défense j'allais dire le ribault qu'ils
s'en défendent les valeurs de la france
éric bocquet vous êtes d'accord avec
florence paris la ministre des armées
qui évoque une politisation
irresponsable des armées c'est qu'une
tribune qui appelle à agir contre
l'islamisme et les hordes de banlieue
mais ainsi qu'ils dénoncent
l'antiracisme moi j'ai trouvé que madame
paris avait tardé un peu réagir et je
trouve aussi que le président de la
république qui est ma connaissance le
chef des armées devrait aussi s'exprimer
sur le sujet parce que vraiment il faut
pas minimiser cette affaire on est face
à aix ou de très sérieux dans un climat
et vous parliez de valeur madame les
valeurs de la république vous lever ses
pertes et est derrière ans naissait
paternité laissez moi parler je lis pas
de notes je réponds ce que vous avez pu
le dire et les valeurs de la république
aujourd'hui la république est absente de
beaucoup de territoires dans ce pays
c'est vrai des milieux ruraux c'est vrai
des banlieues la république abandonner
ces territoires abandonnés cette
population ça n'excuse rien personne
n'approuve ces attentats il faut
absolument les guy forget pour chasser
des auteurs et les juger comme il
convient c'est évident ça va sans dire
mais il faut pas mélanger les choses et
je suis venu vous dire le fond de ma
pensée
le fonds n'a pensé c'est qu'on nous
prépare aujourd'hui 1 2 1 2e tour 2e
édition 2010 est ce maquereau cre de
marine le pen et je pense qu'il ya des
jeux dangereux qui se pratique ici et là
pour faire monter madame le pen pour
qu'elle soit au deuxième tour
effectivement et que l'on présente
monsieur macro comme ultime recours
contre madame gp éric gauthier et
l'exhorté marine le pen elle attend à la
suite de cette tribu il ya là un danger
on joue avec les valeurs de la
république suite de cette tribune et
reebok et marine le pen a tendu la main
aux militaires on est donc quoi dans la
récupération politique vous pensez j'en
suis convaincu enfin attendez c'est
tellement grossier c'est tellement beau
chez les militaires ne peuvent pas son
géopolitique même s'ils sont citoyens
madame le pen leur tend la main pour des
raisons évidentes
voilà elle joue son jeu elle joue son
jeu c'est grave c'est dangereux c'est
inquiétant j'appelle à la plus grande
des vigilances
on est en train de glisser vers quelque
chose d'inquiétant et de dangereux
la république ça n'est pas ça la
république c'est tout le monde la
république c'est les services publics
c'est l'école c'est la santé c'est tous
les grands besoins de la nation
aujourd'hui est une nation pour une
bonne part qui se sent oublié méprisé
négliger il est temps qu'on se
ressaisisse pour donner les moyens aux
services publics notamment d'assurer ses
missions dans l'intérêt de tous est de
combattre
enfin les inégalités ils ne font que
s'aggraver et qui sont le terreau de
tous les extrémismes qu'ils soient
islamistes ou pas d'ailleurs vous
approuvez les norvège cette main tendue
de marine le pen à la suite justement de
cette tribune est bien évidemment déjà
j'aimerais c'est quand même assez assez
amusant c'est monsieur monsieur bloqué
qui nous parle d'un danger avec marine
le pen et le rassemblement national on
sait toujours pas lequel on ne sait pas
encore quelle pluie de grenouilles va
s'abattre sur la france mais alors qu'au
contraire
et puis les services publics ça n'excuse
pas c'est pas parce que les services
publics ne sont pas là on doit égorger
des gens et que lit c'est que ça fait le
terreau de l'islamisme
ça n'exclut absolument rien et oui oui
c'est ce que vous c'est ce que vous
c'est ce que vous dites il a répondu oui
et c'est ce que vous c'est ce que vous
racontez toute façon vous nous
représentez vous nous représentez le
teich que je ne me représente vous ne
représentez pratiquement merci vous ne
représentez pratiquement plus rien en
france ce rassemblement national
rassemble aujourd'hui un très grand
nombre de français et une très grande
majorité de français
et oui marine le pen a parfaitement
raison et bien d'appeler vers l ses
généraux ces militaires qui voudrait
effectivement dus par une fonction tout
à fait démocratique électorale la
rejoindre par leurs votes la rejoindre
et alors fort justement lna cette main
tendue de marine le pen n'avait pas
forcément bien vu on va regarder je vous
propose de regarder cette publication
justement ce mise au point au nom dudit
blog de pierre fabre bernadet qu'à
l'origine donc de cette tribune regarder
une mise au point
madame le pen a parfaitement la
légitimité d'attirer à elle des généraux
il est pour le moins maladroit
d'effectuer une opération de racolage
pour des objectifs électoraux
ensuite est peut-être la plus grave dans
sa lettre et la méconnaissance totale du
monde militaire voilà comment vous
réagissez les normes des ajustements à
cette mise au point qui a été publié sur
ce blog donc de l'auteur de la tribune
oui c'est publié sur un blog et chacun
doit s'exprimer mais je crois encore une
fois que marine le pen qui sera 20 qui
se posent se pose en tout cas avec en
ayant réagi de manière sensée et de
manière intelligente comme il se doit à
la tribune de ses vins généraux en leur
tendant la main
effectivement se positionne parfaitement
en tant que futur chef des armées
président de la république monte à
gauche éric bocquet en tout cas on
s'indigne on tape du poing sur la table
on évoque même la menace de guerre
civile de chasse aux sorcières on va
regarder ce tweet d'eric coquerel on a
un petit peu le temps des militaires
appellent à une chasse aux sorcières à
une éradication à défendre des valeurs
civilisationnelles
à rebours de la république ça finit sur
une menace de guerre civile le pen salue
ces apprentis factieux est rien on se
réveille la chasse aux sorcières menace
de guerre civile est ce que la gauche
n'en fait pas trop
face à ces généraux retraités finalement
éric bocquet faux pas il faut pas en
faire trop faut pas non plus minimiser
d'affaires au cv qui aurait pensé que le
président des états unis donald trump le
6 janvier or et appelé ses partisans à
investir le capital de manière violente
personnes non réponse s'il ne faudrait
pas minimiser et je note d'ailleurs que
madame le pen dans sa dans sa stratégie
qui est la sienne a pris soin de
rassurer les marchés financiers en
disant que l
veillerait à ce que la dette soit
remboursée moi je me bats avec d'autres
pour que la dette soit payée par les
grands entreprises par les gros
patrimoines par tous ceux qui ont
bénéficié de cette pandémie
madame le pen a fait amende honorable
aux marchés financiers en leur donnant
des gages quant au remboursement de la
dette
j'ai noté ce avec beaucoup d'intérêt
pour conclure très rapidement et
l'honneur baise justement sur vous
parlais tout à l'heure des propos de
jean luc mélenchon qui va très loin il
suggère même que le parquet national ça
saisissent de cet appel jeu suite à la
sédition l'armée publié l'an passé
actuelle vous savez j'aimerais
j'aimerais tellement on aimerait
tellement entendre cette gauche qui
s'aplatit devant les islamistes
enfin dénoncé le very very terre de
danger ce véritable danger des attentats
ces gens qui assassine au nom d'une
idéologie monstrueuse et religieuses et
fanatiques qui assassinent des innocents
des français innocents et bien écoutez
je crois que il ferait mieux de garder
leur indignation et de ceux d'être un
petit peu moins indécent voilà
aujourd'hui la gauche est indécente avec
l'islamisme
la gauche devrait se taire et justement
oui effectivement la france a besoin de
routes mais les malheurs de connaissance
des valeurs françaises mérité l'honneur
baise conseillère régionale fn en paca
et merci à vos éric bocquet sénateurs
pcf genoa en république démocratique du
congo des fiv ils demandent le départ
des soldats de l'onu depuis plusieurs
jours des manifestations dénonce
l'inefficacité de la monusco
malgré les vingt mille hommes déployés
sur place une opération de paix qui dure
depuis plus de 20 ans et le milliard de
dollars investis chaque année le
problème d'insécurité persiste les
précisions de walid bey la niche des
tweets en signe d'excusé une vidéo des
plus explicative
les agents de la monusco la mission de
l'organisation des nations unies en
république démocratique du congo sont
dans le viseur de la population
congolaise
samedi un chauffeur a été interpellé
durement par des casques bleus chinois
après qu'il a renversé en voiture l'un
de ces derniers
et poursuit son chemin des éléments du
côté des chinois
une vidéo très commentée sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a poussé la chef de la
monusco à prendre des mesures
la chef de la monusco bintou keita
exprime son indignation concernant la
vidéo qui circule montrant
l'interpellation d'un civil par des
militaires de la monusco a qu à vue mais
elle a ordonné une enquête immédiate
pour établir les faits et prendra les
mesures appropriées rétablir les faits
et redorer dans le même temps l'image
d'une monusco critiqué ces dernières
semaines pour sa passivité
les manifestations se multiplient en
effet pour dénoncer les massacres de
civils
cible présumée des combattants des
forces démocratiques alliées un
sentiment d'insécurité et
d'incompréhension plein dans les plus
grandes villes notamment celles de l'est
du pays
on demande aux autorités de mettre tout
en marche pour que nous puissions voir
que la monusco puissent rentrer chez eux
parce que ce n'est pas normal qu'on
continue à tuer les gens à béni et nous
a tenté des citoyens nous puissions
rester dans les sécurité et que la
monusco rester là sans pour autant
intervenir pour une pression accentuée
par un récent appel à la grève générale
lancé à beni depuis le 5 avril
les écoles sont fermées les taxis-motos
urbains sont à l'arrêt à l'instar des
boutiques des principaux boulevards de
cette ville de deux cent trente mille
habitants samedi à kinshasa la capitale
une marche également mené par les
opposants au président pour exiger le
retour à la paix a été dispersée sur
ordre du gouverneur de la ville et
sachez que demain emmanuel macron
déjeunera à l'elysée justement avec
félix tshisekedi le président de la
république démocratique du congo qui a
d'ailleurs assisté aux obsèques du
président tchadien
après la mort d'idriss deby itno c'était
la semaine passée vient maintenant le
temps de
positions et on l'a appris albert pahimi
padacké a été nommé premier ministre par
décret présidentiel une transition
annoncée d'un an et demi qui sera
assurée par le conseil militaire avec à
sa tête mahamat idriss déby le fils du
président défunt dans la société civile
certaines voix s'élèvent craignant que
cette période charnière ne puissent
aboutir à autre chose car un règne
annoncée du fils d'idriss deby les
rebelles eux se disent prêts au dialogue
pour parvenir à une solution politique
on en parle tout de suite avec jean
claude félix tchicaya et les chercheurs
à l'isf
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france
alors d'abord c'est peut-être une bonne
nouvelle finalement la nomination d'une
personnalité politique civil à la tête
comme premier ministre de la transition
albert pahimi padacké il a déjà lui-même
était premier ministre et il faut le
signaler
il a déjà été premier ministre il est
pendante pendant deux ans il est il fait
partie dans des arcanes du pouvoir
de monsieur feu débit feu débit monsieur
idriss deby était un autocrate président
totalitaire il a été donc premier
ministre de 2016
la 2018 dans la volonté de concentration
des pouvoirs de la part de monsieur
idriss deby il a complètement donc
annulé donc fait disparaître ce poste de
premier ministre pour concentrer donc
pas seulement les pouvoirs politiques
mais aussi les pouvoirs militaires et
économiques et on
il a été nommé donc par son fils dans un
élan dynastique il est nommé par un fils
qui dans la charte dit bien que c'est
lui et non le premier ministre qui va
nommer les autres ministres qui peut
révoquer comme dans cette même charte
d'un militaire parce que le fils est un
militaire donc sans prérogatives de
danon d'annuler de dissoudre la
constitution de dissoudre le
gouvernement de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale
il est prévu dans la constitution que co
décède
d'après du président c'est bien le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui a
pris le pouvoir
donc là on peut comprendre légitimement
que les les oppositions soit soit vent
debout contre ce type ce type d'attitude
et de décisions antidémocratiques
parce qu'une transition à ne peut l'être
que la transition avec une bonne partie
donc d opposition à dialogue une
définition de la stratégie redéfinir
quel type de transition et on ne peut
pas avoir à la tête d'un pays donc un
militaire arrivé au pouvoir par
l'intermédiaire d'un coup d'état parce
qu'il n'a aucune prérogative qui lui
permet d'être président aujourd'hui du
tchad et de présider une une transition
ou à l'intérieur de cette charte de dit
de 18 mois il y a à l'intérieur un
élément qui dit qu'ils peuvent prorogée
de 18 mois encore supplémentaire donc
cette période de transition donc c'est 3
a donc on peut comprendre les doutes la
méfiance à l'égard de cette transition
alors monsieur monsieur padacké qui a
déjà été
premier nice est un opposant conte puis
qu'on peut dire modéré qui depuis un an
et demi était opposant de monsieur débit
mais il a bien dit et qualifié
d'ailleurs la seule personne avec qui la
travaillent c est monsieur idriss déby
d'autocrates donc quelle est la
différence entre une autocratie du père
feu idriss déby d une autocratie qui se
remet en place par l'intermédiaire de me
serrer quelques questions c'est vrai
qu'il ya cette question qui concerne
justement la mise en place d'un conseil
militaire alors que vous le dites
vous-même le pays dispose d'institutions
et que certaines pas dans la norme d'une
république
et puis une autre question aussi des
zones d'ombré autour de la mort d'idriss
deby qui est un fin stratège militaire
on le sait il est mort au front et c'est
ce qui pose beaucoup de questions sur
les circonstances justement de sa mort
idriss deby moi je sais que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion justement l'interviewer le
prêt l'ex le président défunt et il est
il envoyer tout juste une colonne
justement pour tenter de secourir à
l'époque l'ex président centrafricain
françois bozizé donc il a il était
plutôt respectée dans la sous-région
comment sa mort
comment expliquer sa mort cesser ces
zones d'ombré alors il faut bien
s'entendre sur le respect sur la sous
région c'est que les peuples de la
sous-région lui demandait comme il
demande alors à leur présidence d'avoir
une attitude démocratique des décisions
démocratiques
il avait il était à la tête d'une heure
d'une arme d'une armée dit puissante
mais c'est fragile qui aussi commettez
des exactions
il faut savoir qu'à l'intérieur même de
cette armée il ya les personnes très
bien qui aujourd'hui conteste le fait
que son fils ait pris le pouvoir il ya
un schisme à l'intérieur du pouvoir
militaire il ya un schisme à l'intérieur
du pouvoir politique même au sein même
de son parti parce que monsieur débit
tout tout
on parlait de lui comme quelqu'un qui
stabilisait la région mais non ils
stabilisent l instabilité de la région
et l'instabilité de son pays
186e sur 489
pays au monde sur le développement
humain le système de santé public le
centre le système gère les artères donc
c'est important de ton parlait justement
on parle d'un accrochage avec les
rebelles des deux du front pour
l'alternance et la concorde du tchad
mais on parle aussi d'un putsch des
généraux
pour en revenir à ma question initiale
oui alors ben alors la question initiale
j'y arrive c'est vrai que les les
conditions de sa mort sont la version
officielle c'est donc qu'ils soient
morts au front comme un soldat et non
comme un guerrier comme cela a été dit
mais il est un soldat qui est venu au
front devant des opposants est un
mouvement de résistance et non des
rebelles bien tropicalisation du terme
pour certaines géographies certaines
personnes sur cette planète c'est bien
il a bien en face de lui des opposants
est un mouvement de résistance ou à
l'intérieur du fac qu'il n'y a aucun
terrorisme il n'y a aucun extremis il ya
des personnes comme lui
autant il y a trente ans il est arrivé
au pouvoir dans un mouvement similaire
de résistance par rapport à celui qu'il
a donc détrôné avec qui il a travaillé
d'ailleurs monsieur hissène habré qui
aujourd'hui dans les geôles au sénégal
pour les crimes qu'il a perpétrés en
tant que président donc il ya une
confusion un flou sur qu'est ce qui a
conduit à la mort de maîtrise des billes
à la version officielle mais il ya
d'autres versions il ya aussi les fêtes
news des tests copiera sioniste et
complotistes mais on voit bien que il
souvent il se mettait en scène sur les
théâtres de conflits mais en tant que
président c'était quand même assez
risqué d'aller sur le front même si
c'était un soldat aguerri ya toujours le
risque d'être blessé ou des tués et là
notamment il était contre des opposants
qui aujourd'hui appellent appel au
dialogue donc à l'intérieur de l'armée
et du mouvement et est aidé de la classe
politique même au sein de la majorité
mais surtout dans l'opposition il serait
d'accord pour nous aider
négociations à dialogue avec tous les
tchadiens que ce soit la classe
politique les mouvements sonico la
diaspora tchadienne en france donc on
voit bien que est ce que c'est une
vision vengeresse qu deux des fils mais
on voit bien que ce qui a été validée
même sur le plan international notamment
de la france sur ce s'est éteint de
transition ce chef d'état qui n'est pas
légitime au regard des droits
fondamentaux des droits internationaux
droit international donc il sait tout et
et fouet ou pied alors que le tchad
comme l'afrique a besoin d'institutions
fortes et non des hommes forts
autocratique un chef de la transition
qui est soutenu par la france puisque
emmanuel macron enfin en tout cas macron
ces déplacés au tchad tout récemment
c'est assez c'est assez consternant
nous pensions que l'état français
notamment monsieur macron donc c'est
avait venu donc aller vers la fin de la
françafrique ne vois bien mais comment
parler de comment parler donc d'un g5
d'un g5 sahel qui qui travaille à une
meilleure gouvernance aussi en même
temps qu'un combat contre le contre le
terrorisme est adoubé une gouvernants
merci d'autocratie de 19,6 donc il ya
une incohérence totale et sa stupéfait
ça même ça concerne on pas seulement là
les populations d'afrique mais aussi les
populations françaises qui se demandent
pourquoi au nom de la république on
soutient un tel pouvoir
merci c'est jean claude félix tchicaya
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur un
lip ce fin et c'est la fin de cette
émission prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes
restez avec nous sur rtl
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas le confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir com